[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien bonjour bonjour bienvenue ici en
direct de londres vous voyez que les
préparatifs pour la deuxième partie sont
en train d'être effectués sur le plateau
petite nouveauté vous verrez des logos
canal web sur sur ce plateau
la voilà vous voyez que voilà le logo
canal web ici en fond d'écran qui
signale notre présence ici à londres
pour cette retransmission exclusive sur
internet en partenariat avec brenda
games donc deuxième partie très
intéressante deuxième partie très
intéressante puisque ça y est chronique
à les pièces blanches
il a très bien repousser kasparov dans
la première partie il maintenant c'est à
lui de prendre l'initiative et on va
avoir en fait ce qu'a préparé kramnik
pour essayer de faire face à kasparov et
aussi on va avoir le choix de kasparov
dans la défense alors la question qui se
pose c'est évidemment quelle ouverture
va choisir kramnik déjà dans ce match
est-ce qu'il va ouvrir mais le pion du
roi ou avec le pion de la dame et
ensuite en fonction de ce choix mais on
va voir aussi kasparov garde ses options
favorite dans les ouvertures ou s'il a
préparé deux des nouveautés on verra par
exemple sur quatre est ce qu'il choisit
sa fameuse sicilienne un âge d'or ou sur
des 4es ce qui revient à ses amours de
l'est alien ou est-ce qu'il va à prétot
jouer quelque chose de plus solide comme
la rue la défense grünfeld alors ici on
voit raymond keane en train de présenter
le match au public dans la salle raymond
keane qui nous l'espérons dès demain
aura un micro afin que nous puissions
l'entendre actuellement ce n'est pas le
cas malheureusement
mais ça sera sûrement fait pour la
troisième partie voyez c on se met en
place doucement pour 7 pour cette
retransmission
l'organisation est en train de se
peaufiner il nous reste encore quinze
partis pour arriver à quelque chose de
bien
donc la raison qu'il le grand maître
anglais organisateurs cet événement
alors à signaler que raymond keane et
danny king commente ce soir après le
match
un résumé anglais de 26 minutes de cette
partie avec leurs propres commentaires
résumé que vous pouvez voir en différé à
propos de la partie de dimanche dernier
alors se résumer en anglais sera suivie
d'un résumé en français juste après et
diffusée sur la partie française et
anglaise en même temps les deux
diffuseurs diffusant ses émissions qui
se déroule les unes après les autres
donc partie très importante je rappelle
puisque vladimir kramnik à les blancs et
donc il est susceptible de pouvoir
prendre l'aventage dans ce début de
partie alors qu'on voit sur le terrain
journalistes en train de poser quelques
questions semble-t-il l organisation il
a pas l'air content on attend les
joueurs probablement ils vont pas tarder
alors le premier jour ils étaient un
petit peu en retard et cinq minutes de
retard là il est 15h à ma montre donc il
devrait pas tarder il devrait pas tarder
on va on va attendre calmement que les
joueurs arrivent à noter quand même
aussi que canal web est présent sur
l'ensemble des tournois du grand chelem
sur toute l'année
pas uniquement pour ce championnat du
monde puisque on retransmet ont fait des
reportages sur les grands tournois de
l'année comme v15 et linares sarajevo où
dortmund voilà les joueurs
voilà les joueurs
eh bien
eh bien on les attend mais oui voilà
raymond keane fait ainsi mis en garde
pas vouloir rentrer sur la scène est
peut-être ont-ils quelques préparatifs à
faire avant de rentrer sur scène alors
vous remarquerez que les chaises ont été
échangés la chaise de kasparov se trouve
maintenant à voile à vladimir kramnik
donc il fait sa rentrée sur scène
vladimir kramnik qui donc va se
retrouver du côté blanc donc vous voyez
que les chaises ont été échangés il a
choisi de garder son fauteuil évidemment
et la fameuse de chaises de kasparov
on rappelle que kasparov a refusé toutes
les chaises qu'on lui a proposé il a
choisi de choisir dont fela choisi cette
ce type de chaises la plus coût plus
solide beaucoup plus dur pour l'as
kasparov qui fait son entrée sur scène
voilà les deux joueurs se serrent la
main comme il est d'usagé
kasparov a changé de cravates ou entre
les oui ça y est il nous fait son rituel
il enlève la montre ouh là là attention
alors là ça veut dire qu'il est chaud il
n'avait pas enlevé la montre la première
partie à paris a gagné là il tombe la
montre notre ami kasparov comme il le
fait souvent dans les tournois il tombe
la montre et puis vous allez voir
peut-être normalement un petit peu au
début de la partie il est susceptible un
petit peu son autre cravate
ça arrive aussi souvent et récits de
partie et c'est le pion de la dame qui a
été jouée par kramnik d2 d4 mokrani qu'a
choisi le l'ouverture du plan de la dame
s'est pas vraiment une surprise ça fait
partie de son de son répertoire
cavaliers si ça voilà donc tout de suite
probablement probablement après ces
quatre voilà on va voir tout de suite
est-ce que kasparov a joué g6 c'est la
question pour entrer soit dans une grume
feld soit dans une défense est indienne
voilà alors là ils se se prend la tête
ah qu'est-ce qu'il nous a préparés
attention si haut et oui j'ai six g6
silvano justice alors la question après
cavalli c-32 chronique
est-ce que travnik vaches mechali 6/3
6/4 mijoux calais c3 la question qui va
se poser tout de suite c'est est-ce que
kaspar aujoulat grünfeld avec des 5 ou
alors l'estonienne est fou g7 et là on
retrouve le grand kasparov des années 80
début des années 90 où ils avaient des
résultats fantastiques avec avec
l'estonienne kaia lycée 3-2 kramnik la
question maintenant fou g7 ou bien et d5
ac - c'est moins chaud des cinq défenses
grünfeld c'est une défense solide mais
difficile de gagner avec la grüne fait
quand même
alors à moins que kasparov et préparer
vraiment quelque chose de tout à fait
neuf là grünfeld c'est la défense
employée par tous les champions du monde
fis charles à jouer karpov la jouer
évidemment ils ont tous joué là grünfeld
mais c'est moins c'est moins agressif
probablement que l'estonienne c'est une
contre attaque centrale avec les pièces
à distance voyez le fou g7 maintenant
qui s'est placée sur la grande diagonale
et les noirs vont essayer de contre
attaquer le centre blanc qui est très
fort puisque vous noterez qu'il ya deux
pions sans trop blanc les pions des 4 et
e4 et l'a donc voilà ça une première
contre attaque des noirs le coup c'est 5
pression sur le centre blanc avec le fou
g7 placé en embuscade et ça y est les
blancs sont sous pression il faut qu'ils
essaient de maintenir leur centre de
pions intacte au centre pour pouvoir se
garantir en avantage des espaces donc
tout là toute la subtilité cette
ouverture réside dans cette idée dans la
foulée 3 en protégeant surprotège le
pion le pion des quatre en même temps on
développe ses pièces hélas les noirs
peuvent jouer quantité de variantes
possibles
assailli la kasparov a touché un petit
peu son hôte cravate qu'est ce qui nous
a préparé la kasparov
sur la green fel alors je sais pas si
notre commentateur
eloi va pouvoir et loire où l'enjeu va
pouvoir nous rejoindre pour vous
expliquer un petit peu les arcanes de
cette défense
vous aviez ray que je vous avouerai que
je suis pas un spécialiste de cette
défense je pourrais vous donner les
grandes idées les grandes idées qu'ont
les noirs ou les où les blancs dans
cette dans cette défense donc les blancs
un développement assez harmonieux avec
donc un centre très fort et les noirs
aussi de contre attaquer ce centre
notamment sur case noire puisque vous
voyez que le pion c5 fait pression sur
des quatre avec le fou g7 le coup
cavaliers ses six plus tard le cavalier
b8 qui est menée en c6 rajoutera de la
pression la dame des huit peut dans
certaines variantes éventuellement se
poster sur la case à 5 pour attaquer le
pion c3 et grosse pression des noirs son
casque noir et blanc s'il arrive à tenir
ce centre on va avoir un avantage des
espaces importants et un centre très
fort
c'est une ouverture où la moindre erreur
de la part des noirs provoque un
écrasement spatiale les blancs prennent
tout l'espace et après déroulent leurs
coûts pour envahir le camp noir donc il
faut être très précis avec les noirs la
moindre erreur se paye cash
à la casse parfait réfléchit et on n'a
pas vu on n'a pas vu la préparation de
kasparov plutôt sur sur l'estonienne qui
l'a décidé dans ce match et alors là
grünfeld c'est plutôt une variante à nu
lente pour les noirs on cherche à faire
nul on n'a pas trop d'ambition de gains
la différence avec l'estonienne qui et
qui laisse les blancs occuper le centre
on bloque le centre on essaie d'attaquer
sur les droits c'est que c'est une une
défense qui sous-entend une contre
attaque violente donc il peut y avoir
des contre chances des deux côtés très
importante
là c'est est ce que les noirs arrivent à
contenir le centre blanc elle n'a pas
l'air content kasparov c'est curieux
c'est curieux à quoi il réfléchit à quoi
il peut bien réfléchir à quoi ils
peuvent et c'est curieux quand même très
qui ont ils pouvaient s'attendre quand
même que krainik joue des 4 qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
kasparov qui réfléchit en 1 8e coup
c'est une arme très connu il a forcément
préparé quelque chose il mais il ne sait
pas il n'a pas l'air il n'a pas l'air
sûre de son coup là notre ami alors que
loire volanges est en train de nous
rejoindre
donc kasparov qui a pas l'air du tout
serein du tout du tout du tout c'est
très très curieux on est toujours dans
l'ouverture évidemment c'est une défense
grünfeld c'est très connu qu'est ce
qu'on fait là jouent évidemment des
centaines de fois il connaît ça par
coeur il ya tout analysé etc
il a joué ça comme karpov des milliers
de fois à quoi peut-il bien réfléchir et
peut-être il a peur la préparation
cramique il faut dire que dans la
première partie kramnik là quand même
bien surpris il est peut-être reçu un
petit coup et cela ça lui a fait ça
serait une nouveauté vos kasparov de
perdre confiance il n'a jamais perdu
confiance kasparov et si la peur
peut-être il est peut-être il va prendre
peur de vos chroniques
en tout cas il a alors non mais il faut
bon il ya que vous y est si quelque
chose qu'il faut voir c'est que dans ce
début de partie
kasparov ce sa place et mon c est sur
cette ouverture il devait s'attendre ça
aujourd'hui
il doit se remémorer en fait toutes les
idées qu'il a dû voir à l'analyse
c'est surtout ça qui lui prend du temps
évidemment en train de se remémorer
toutes les idées pour savoir pour bien
se placer dans la partie bien se placer
dans le plan qu'il a envie de se placer
en cra nick alors eloi nous a rejoint
stéphane bonjour à tous qui êtes là sur
le net en train de suivre ce match
d'exception alors vais devenir chronique
à jouer une défense grünfeld stéphane
c'est effectivement enfin bien le
testeur aurait jeune défenseur et
laissez moi je suis pas encore tout à
fait chaud voilà moi je m'attendais à
une défense italienne alors ah non non
non les stades n'est pratiquement plus
pratiqué par garry kasparov depuis un
bout de temps puisqu'il ya trop de
problème tout simplement dans les stands
yens actuellement et peut-être on
pouvait s'attendre à une nouveauté de
kasparov il aurait pu j'aurais beaucoup
puisqu'il ya des pointes dans toutes les
variantes de l'estonienne actuellement
la bonne file dallaire de faire nul très
facilement j'en ai parlé avec the thief
dorfman champion france 98 qui était
cette année champion sans aucun à
l'échiquier de démonstration
effectivement la graine feld pour
l'instant est très très solide elle en a
et bien il faudrait paramétrer la bête
ce que nous allons faire rapidement
effectivement si l'image déborde cela on
va dire on va revenir l'échiquier réel
tout de suite revenir à l'échiquier une
tout de suite voilà on va essayer de de
commenter un petit peu cette position
donc fou et 3 effectivement c'est un
coup
c'est un coup non donc il n'est pas le
plus le plus joué dans cette position
stéphane ce n'est pas le coup le plus
jouer donc voilà tout simplement non
joue plutôt fou et 2 suivi dans cette
liste d'options c'est la fameuse la
rente iphone de tourbe et un faux à
trois c'est une surprise pour garry
kasparov
évidemment la grünfeld grammy qui
attendait il n'y a pas de lien aucun
doute là dessus donc je pense que nous
allons en fait dans un premier temps
paramétrer bien le l'échiquier de
démonstration pour pouvoir vous en dire
beaucoup plus il va m'en occuper voilà
donc ici garry kasparov réfléchit
toujours huitième coup dans cet étonnant
sans réflexion puisque évidemment il
connaît très bien cette ouverture il
pouvait s'attendre cette ouverture de la
porte de chroniques à saillé damas 5
voilà damas cinq salles il a choisi sa
variante damas cinq tout de suite
pression sur l'option c3
la dame menace d'un procès trop avec
échec donc indirectement ça fait
pression aussi sur des canevas la dame
des deux c'est le coup logique c'est
l'écologie condé clou le pion c3
maintenant sur pied ces cinq prendre des
quatre ont fait ces trois prendre les
quatre et sur dame prend dames on peut
faire je crois prend dames on peut
amener le roi puisque les dames sont
échangés c'est pas très dangereux et on
évite de d'enlever le cavalier le fou de
la place qu'ils occupent
attention parce que c'est quand même
très très surprenant cette position
s'est elle est réputée elle a la
réputation d'être bonne pour les noirs
puisque à priori tout le monde sait
c'est un principe connu et reconnu dans
la défense de felt il est noir arrive en
finale ils n'ont plus aucun problème
donc ici je pense que chroniqueur
chaussée prend des quatre c'est rangs
des cadres dame prend des deux stars of
week as pas on va jouer ça doit prendre
deux rois francs d2 et là on est dans
les partis
ou karpov avait essayé cette position je
crois qu'entre kasparov lui-même il
remanie chine aussi qu'un grand
spécialiste qui a essayé ça un grand
maître ukrainien et en général les
résultats des noirs dans cette position
sont très très satisfaisant peut-être
cramique à préparer quelque chose
cramé à jacques les avantages alors
qu'ils étaient de kramis qui est en
train de encore une fois de surprendre
kasparov en proposant cette finale entre
guillemets qui annule est-ce que kramnik
d'ailleurs castorf doute nous allons
d'europe là dessus la tête de kasparov
là dessus alors il tendrait à se dire
mais il se fout de ma gueule et ça doit
être ça kasparov là il est il est très
très dubitative et c'est ce qui me fait
le petit lac est ce qu'il est en train
de me faire question of qui bouge
beaucoup il bouge beaucoup on voit sa
jambe droite qui est très nerveuse sky
sports qui est assez tendue et une fois
de plus on peut dire que c'est quand
même une constante dans ses deux
premières parties c'est kasparov qui est
surpris dans l'ouverture et oui il
semblerait que kaspar sa surprise à
l'ouverture encore une fois alors est ce
qu'on peut oui alors il faut envoyer
l'échiquier de démonstration nous allons
le régler en direct devant vous devant
vos yeux ébahis
ça va être un réglage d'enfer alors
voilà ne bougeait plus voilà échiquier
démonstration puisque on va le régler
ici pour qu'elle apparaisse qu'ils
apparaissent dans l'écran un kasparov a
joué il a joué fou angers 4 voilà oui
nous mais là nous allons régler mais on
revient l'échiquier démonstration tout
de suite sous g4 de kasparov alors
évidemment on a un petit problème la
voilà voilà très bien donc là on va
jouer les coups sur cet échiquier de
démonstration damas 5
dam des deux au dam des deux est la
fouge et 4 de kasparov donc floue g4 qui
doit être ou un coup aussi connu oui
tout à fait non il n'y a aucun doute que
vladimir kramnik et est au courant de ce
qui se passe dans cette position alors
là on joue quand vous poussez cas très
loin
bon là c'est les grands les grands
thèmes de la défense bonne file donc une
seconde puisque dès que j'aurai attaché
mon micro
c'est la magie du direct avec ce 7e chez
qui des démonstrations qui n'était pas
bien installée voilà je vais tout de
suite pouvoir expliquer les enjeux réels
de la défense d'une femme c'est bien
entendu le pion des cadres puisque les
blancs d'une majorité centrale et il
essaie de tenir leurs pulsions des 84
elle est jouée kramnik à tour bien
tourbe et un tour bien très logique
coûts qui enlève la tour de la diagonale
du fou j'ai sept g7 et la contrôler la
cave et en plus ce taux est à petit
viciant bien puisque le profit de la
colonie verbe est tout simplement et
absorptions bessette ici voilà moi alors
qu'est ce qu'on remarque c'est que les
deux couloirs lutte directement pour la
case des quatre le fou g7 qui étaient
ici la taxe directe et le fou g4 il veut
c'est changer contre le kenya 3 qui est
un défenseur de l'as cannes donc voilà
les grands objectifs de la partie pour
les droits
voilà donc là c'est connu encore pour
les joueurs alors pourquoi kasparov a
pas choisi la variante tiens prends des
quatre avec échange des dames et bien
probablement parce qu'il a trouvé mieux
je pense que quand on a trouvé quelque
chose de bon le fait est que c'est je
m'en souviens d'une façon assez
aléatoire de cette position parce que je
ne joue pas la défense de noël donc je
n'ai pas la certitude que ce n'était pas
fou g4 d'abord c'est peut-être qu'on est
bien dans le nord ce qui se fait de
mieux dans au niveau de la théorie
moderne mais je suis surpris quand à
l'inflexion de kasparov quand même parce
que il connaît très bien la game fun
pourquoi est-ce qu'il réfléchit alors
que vraisemblablement il sait exactement
quoi faire dans cette position ils
hésitent peut-être à jouer au foot
france 3 où on sait bien que donner un
fou contre kramix est pas toujours une
bonne chose la chronique quand il agit
en effet les massacres et les petits
class parole et encore une fois il aime
bien il faut alors peut-être cramique
est malade il a choisi d ouverture
kasparov est obligé de donner sa paire
de foot peut-être c'est possible à
kasparov a joué il a joué le coup à
cette assise soit 8,0 ça revient c'est
comme un con tre karpov alors a7 a6 donc
il n'a pas peur de tout reprendre tubes
et 7 non il n'en a pas peur il pourrait
probablement en avoir peur effectivement
mais tant qu'on met sa tête un coup il
faut voir ça faut absolument l'envisager
il faut voir ça il fait bon visage
m'avoir l'échiquier démonstration de
tout efficaces démonstration qu est ce
qu on voit bien à psion emprise kasparov
ne l'a pas défendu donc évidemment nous
envisageons directement possibilité
voient la possibilité d'admirer à mener
donc en train de voir une variante
évidemment c'est pas la position réelle
tout reprend 17 tu te prends mais cette
semble gagner en avion il faut bien le
fond de l'avenir mais effectivement les
noirs obtiendrait du jeu c'est
vraisemblable probablement joint le coup
qui a blessé six qui a l'air d'être
beaucoup dans cette position avec l'idée
de jouer bien entendu plus tard petit
rock et tourbez vite gagnant la colonne
b avec des cases d'entrée sur la
première rangée des blancs dans
sacrifice de pion à moyen-terme
sacrifice de plus un moyen terme la
voilà les deux joueurs sont partis
classiques dont elle va revoir ce plan
ça se met alors en gros voilà voilà
landreau il en est là parce qu'on peut
noter si quand même s'il est très joli
changement de chaises les chaises et les
jambes ou les logos oui il ya des looks
and web
il ya des loups au canal web qui sont
nouveaux alors donc la voilà donc la
très jolie
c'est très joli sac ravi de jouer mes
chroniques se pressent pas donc famille
qu'évidemment on sait qu'il est à gauche
puisqu'il a le fauteuil le plus grand
non pas le plus grand mais surtout le
fauteuil le plus classique
exactement alors bon bayonne en
attendant qu'ils reviennent on va
évidemment revenir à la rame micro vient
d'abord on le prend en train de revenir
une note son couple en très classique il
tranquille trame unique n 1 ce match et
n'a pas besoin d'avoir trop de pression
il est assez tranquille bac et blanc il
est il ne risque pas de lui arriver
grand chose a priori c'est clair que
qu'est ce qu'il va faire reprendre le ps
qui sont hostiles à kramnik de prendre
un client comme ça si un parti là car
allah karpov ça de prendre l'option sa
réponse est plutôt un défenseur oui oui
c'est vrai car point fort est peut-être
pression cramer qui a pris des pions
bien pire ça on s'en rappelle mais bon
ici je ne sais pas s'ils ramenaient qui
est prêt à donner
l'initiative a kasparov puisqu'on sait
que kasparov avec l'initiative c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez mais
percutant ouais surtout avec des douches
ou alors mai
ce quoi 6 l'idée aussi les noirs c'est
sûrement la menace c'est d7 d5
mais c'est le médecin qui évidemment les
noirs jouent ici pour la case c4 1 17 b
5 pour et ça prendre l'espace donc à un
crâne il va jouer
granic va jouer il va jouer ça y est up
to reprend bessette tout premier set il
a pris le pion kramnik appris le pion il
ya pas peur il a pas peur il a accepté
le pion empoisonné de kasparov
et oui s'est pas laissé démonter kramnik
alors là c'est quand même étonnant parce
que cramique à l'eiblen position
tranquille un pion de plus bon
évidemment c'est à double tranchant
puisque on va le voir là les
l'initiative 2k sports va se développer
très fortement
donc ça arrive souvent à ce niveau là de
la compétition surtout pour avec
kasparov c1
c'est un fan de ce type de pseudo
sacrifices on offre on offre un pion
donc est-ce qu'on va vous faire un pion
en échange de quoi on va voir que les
noirs vont gagner des temps de
développement vont sortir leur pièce
très vite et vont pouvoir contre-attaqué
puisque les blancs ont rejoué deux fois
la même pièce ils ont joué la tour
maintenant de tout premier set ça prend
un pion mais ils n'ont pas sorti leurs
fous par exemple leur fou f1 il est
toujours toujours à la maison
alors ici on a on voit l'échiquier de
démonstration où le coût n'a pas encore
été joué donc je le joue tout reprend
bessette est donc là l'idée tout
simplement pour les noirs ça va être
deux probablement ne joue le coup
cavaliers c6 lecavalier
venir cette case ici pointé en rouge
voilà le cavalier vite revenir sur cette
case et dc il va contrôler le centre
contre-attaqué au centre sur la case des
quatre contrôles et des quatre menaces
et probablement des échanges généraux
par exemple vous prendre cavaliers f3
puis on prend fut ensuite plus on prend
des 4 puis on prend des cadres d'en
prendre un méchant je reprends et on
gagne le pion des quatre puisque le
cavalier fou contrôler ses pions donc ça
serait une pression très forte des noirs
sur le centre blanc qui obligerait les
pions à s'avancer ou qui obligerait les
blancs à trouver une réponse en tout cas
cette pression supplémentaire des noirs
eh bien nous recevons maintenant ici un
invité l'invité est avec nous puisque
c'est le maître le maître international
robert fontaine alors bonjour robert
bonjour alors tu as suivi de le début de
cette partie mais je viens juste
d'arriver en fait donc j'ai juste
regardé les coûts et ouais donc jacques
c'est une graine fade et krainik
beaucoup du temps d'avancé déjà donc il
doit être mieux préparés mais je connais
pas beaucoup cette variante 1 on va
essayer de la commenter la victoire
j'essaie de te trouver un micro parce
que normalement on a un micro alors qui
voilà ici petit micro voilà avec lequel
tu vas pouvoir commenter avec nous un
petit peu cette ce début de partie alors
faut rappeler robert que tu es maître
international
tu as joué le championnat de france en
août et là tu reviennes du championnat
du monde junior
oui tout à fait comment ça s'est passé
mais très mal cet été versé 1,6 au
cubain qui a gagné c'est ça oui c'est un
cubain qui a gagné assez facilement
parce qu'il a gagné avec un point et
demi d'avancé et il avait été déjà
champion du monde une ronde avant la fin
donc vraiment il a gagné facilement quoi
alors on va on va te mettre le micro
voilà ici tu vois tu vas essayer de le
mettre ici sur le haut de ta chemise
c'est un micro cravate comme ça
s'appelle voilà donc voilà robert
fontaine qui reviennent du championnat
du monde junior il faut en passer par là
avant de faire le sauveur du monde
seniors
donc là bas tu tu vas tu viens allant
devant pour suivre ce match évidemment
oui oui parce que c'est c'est vraiment
une grosse affiche que les deux
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
donc c'est ça va être intéressant alors
à ce que tu as suivi la première partie
aussi on a l'impression avec cette
deuxième partie culte rami que pose des
problèmes à kaspar on a une vertu
oui là et il a des surprises hier
dimanche
kasparov déjà enjoint la berlinoise et
là il a l'air encore de mieux connaître
donc bon c'est rare de voir kasparov
comme ça a pris à son propre jeu parce
qu'en général c'est lui qui prépare très
bien ces ouvertures et surprendre
l'adversaire avait des nouveautés et la
chronique en même temps j'ai le
sentiment la phase avec ces deux
variantes là que la kasparov s'il veut
récupérer son pion par exemple pas si on
va être obligé de donner un fou oui mais
c'est pas trop dans l'esprit de notre
stand de donner le fouillent le seul
atout des noirs c'est d'avoir du
dynamisme avec la paire de fouet
développement durable dans les pièces
donc je sais pas si faux problème 3 par
exemple je ne sais pas si c'est une
bonne idée
c'est un très bon donc il va essayer
sûrement de sortir son cavalier v8 sur
les cases c6 salaires logique comme
coûts par exemple parce que ça protège
le pion recettes aussi sa contre attaque
au centre
et puis ça menace peut-être entre
guillemets de faire un petit rock et
peut être que cette position était au
rythme du moins quelques rames lingwala
connaître puisqu'il a utilisé seulement
cinq minutes de réflexion donc on va
échanger nos micros je vais essayer de
passer sur l'échiquier de démonstration
alors on va on va essayer de passer sur
l'échiquier de démonstration à
s'améliorer qu'il soit décalé alors eh
oui il ya un problème de décalage
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire alors
oui c'est de faire un réglage des
démonstrations alors si on peut remettre
l'échiquier de démonstration on allait
voir des problèmes techniques le début
de deux variantes aujourd'hui c'est très
curieux il semblerait que comme il
semblerait que l'image soit un petit peu
allongée voilà on règle ça à la
technique
évidemment en ces mots on a une arme à d
une armada pardon de techniciens
évidemment qu'ils surveillent cette
cette retransmission
heureusement qu'on ait aider
techniquement et l'a donc sur cet
échiquier démonstration on va tout de
suite envisagée le coup donc
probablement de kasparov karellis issia
wazi c6 qui viendrait sur le cac c'est
si ça lors de ses six cavaliers ici
contrôlerait vous aurez une contre
attaque sur le plan des cadres des
blancs on peut voir déjà l'idée de
cavalli sait si c'est de faire une
pression sur des quatre comme tu l'as
dit et il pourrait menacer déjà fou
prend m3 alors on va montrer la variante
donc cavalier c6 suit et la menace alors
par exemple sylvain joué par joe 2 par
exemple ou aux deux grands cavaliers f3
on aurait faut prendre cavaliers 3 puis
on prend par exemple
par exemple tu comprends puis on prend
des 4 puis on prend des cas puis on
prend des 4 puis on prend des cas et
d'un pro d2 d'emprunt des deux et on
perçoit que le pion en d4 blanc et et en
l'air maintenant il est dans l'air
puisque il attaqué par le cavalier sait
si c'est par le fou je souhaite et par
le fou g7
voilà voilà une variante possible
évident alors venir c'est une des idées
une des idées de cavaliers sait s'ils
font bien sûr sur cavani ces six femmes
ne peut jouer
qu'est-ce qui peut jouer alors il veut
jouer peut-être quatre où cinq manches
il faut que j'essaie voilà par exemple
ouais ouais on va pas d'autres coups en
fait non puisque des cinq est impossible
évidemment à cause de foot français 3
way à noter donc par exemple cavale et
ses 600 voir venir la variante si les
blancs pour empêcher la variante
convient de donner du tout des cinq
attaquants lecavalier
évidemment les noirs reprendrai avec le
fou g7 en c3 et la dame blanche est
perdue puisque elle ne peut pas partir
puisque le fou cloud la dame sur le roy
on voit kasparov réfléchir moi il a
l'air fière de ce qu'elle était de
quelques questions un bon cavalli c6 et
e5 donc avalé c615 aller en normal alors
voyons une autre variante e5 donc qui a
l'air normal puisqu'il alors ça a des
avantages et ses inconvénients sûrement
parce que bon évidemment sa bouche
le fou g7 qui tape sur un mur oui donc
du coup la casse des quatre est mieux
protégé mais mais les pions blancs du
coup ont perdu leur mobilité
aussi c'est vrai mais bon il faut il a
quand même est-ce qu'il n'ya plus en
plus oui oui quand même comme un pion
plus donc mon bon maintenant sur re5
kasparov peut jouer petit petit rock est
suivi de tour des huit avec quand même
pas mal de jeu ouais vraiment ici il
faut il être cavalli sait si ce n'est
pas forcément plus il peut commencer par
petit roquet le petit rock s'écrit fille
encore le pion aux 7
mais bon je pense que cela est valable
on voit le temps dont 4 sur wii
il est tout reprend 7 a l'air vraiment
dangereux pour les pour les blancs donc
je pense plutôt que sur petit rock
kramnik peut jouer fouet 2 alors on va
voir on va avoir cet ordre puisque l'on
s'éloigne et donc des autres
propositions le travail et ses six cas
l'air pas mal quand même
tout à fait robert nous propose petit
rock voilà liberacion petit rock avec
sacrifice du pion 7
et si les blancs prennent ce pion robert
tu proposes to be ou cavaliers séisme
qu'a blessé six sept huit attaquants
gain de temps sur la toile
la toro 7 et le pion des 4 et là
vraiment les noirs on
une grosse initiative consignes
initiative et puis on peut supposer qu
ensuite ils à tours à huit par exemple
venir sur la classe des vite ou l'autre
tour où tous rêvent des villes chiites
ou rabais 8 plutôt mal a plutôt l
inverse l'autre tour et puis on
garderait la case des huit pour la tour
est vite et donc là les tours aurait un
super jeu toutes les pièces noir jouent
et les blancs ont toujours par ok tout à
fait donc ça peut être très dangereux
montour recette est vraiment vraiment
passé un coup il suffit d un suicidaire
on a peut-être faut deux feux ne serait
quand même logique et pour développer
les pièces et évoquer le plus rapidement
possible donc là petit rock food par une
petit rock
alors on va revenir ici et vente au
robert propose tout simplement jouer
fuhe 2 ne pas prendre le pion et faire
soi-même petit roi qu'assez rapidement
pour bien protéger son centre oui donc
c'est clair que maintenant chronique est
beaucoup mieux préparé sur cette
variante 1 on voit il a quasiment 20
minutes d'avancement non alors le temps
évidemment ça joue on a vu déjà que le
temps on pouvait avoir une importance
fondamentale
lors de la première partie dimanche
puisque kasparov avait jusqu'à une heure
de retard et on pensait que kramis
pouvait éventuellement me poser de gros
problèmes en coupe à salé kasparov a
joué avant une prof 3 surprenant il
donne donc son fou il donne son façon
fous sont fous ils donnent au four il
donne son fouquet
alors quelle idée sur qui on prélève
trois là les noirs les blancs vont
répondre tout de suite comme france 3
déjà c'est cet article une disposition
espèce non va pas laisser on n'a pas
laissé gaspard et qu'une pièce devant ce
même si cela s'est fait hors de question
donc ravis que je veux plus on prend 3
c'est sûr il faut attendre qu'il
revienne il faudra faire un grand plan
un plan large tout de suite
voilà un plan large sur la scène là on
n'a pas mis cramique revenir voilà donc
le cramique ici je vais tout de suite on
prend les trois vous allez voir ça va
être immédiat voilà où il joue
évidemment créé la classe par off
devrait enchaîner qui régissent et 6
voilà ça il a enchaîné
ça arrive souvent quand on fait un
échange comme ça c'est qu'on a vu le
coup d'après 1 c'est un peu notre star
ouverte
tout à fait ils échangent comme ça à
l'évidence est suivi forcément du coup
rapidement puisque c'est qu'on a calculé
une suite
oui exactement donc ici la meneuse
kasparov et puis on prend des quatre
maintenant alors je demande pourquoi
pourquoi 4 avoir feint d'avoir fait
[ __ ] en l'air froid et leur très bien
pu faire cavaler 6,6 tout de suite oui
tout à fait mais alors là et jouer tout
point f3 plus tard
il ya des subtilités qu'on n'a pas
comprendre
ouais mais ça doit être ça date alors là
qui peuvent être amenées que 5,5 comme
on l'avait dit mais maintenant peut-être
même tours détours des huit directement
pour les cd4 et david tout directement
on voit pas la différence avec le
carillon f3 et le fond le g4 faut pas
trop pour l'instant non
ouais c'est curieux
peut-être il avait peur d'un coup comme
camel et j5 qui était possible peut-être
ou la non je suis 2 h 3 non je pense
quand on voit pas bien fait mon père
porte maintenant on va venir on va
revenir à la position donc la pression
de kasparov sur des quatre alors avec le
fou g7 aussi qui fait pression pendant
le fou g7 ici fait pression sur des 4 et
la menace des noirs actuellement c'est
le pion 6,5 ici qui peut prendre en d4
donc faire un échange généralisé
récupérer l'option centrale avec une
bonne position
oui mais bien un père de foucauld les
blancs quand même et si les noirs
parviennent à récupérer des quatre on
s'aperçoit que la structure branchement
est cassé on avait pu en oublie un f3 à
f2 donc la position noir sera préférable
donc même si les blancs la paire de fou
c'est ça pas beaucoup d'importance alors
je suis un temps de regarder nos coûts
comme tour b2 peut-être pour reprendre
de la tour en d2 sur par exemple tombé
deux pions 24 d'accord donc la casse par
an pour granik pardon pourrait jouer je
sais pas ça t'embête éventuellement mais
ça arrange ou encore la même pièce c'est
un jeu la même pièce ou maintenant sur
puis on prend des quatre plus grands des
quatre ont pu en prendre quatre
évidemment sur dan preda on reprendre la
tour et on contrôle très bien de ce que
fait la case des quatre avec le fou et
la tour c'est une idée il devait tomber
n'a pas l'air vraiment dans l'esprit de
la position quand même ce serait plutôt
un coup comme 5 comme on l'a dit alain
donc le coup ici je préconise robert
plutôt qui sans qu'ils aient à la plus
logique le coût 5
ici qui bouchent le fou g7 qui tape qui
tapent dessus et qui peut pas sortir
devant la roue avec à idées par exemple
si on a le temps f4 ou g2 mais bon ça ce
serait un rêve pour les blancs alors f4
foulée de stellar jouer ici le pion f300
lacazette 4 et ensuite mettre le fou sur
cette diagonale avec une très jolie
encore une fois diagonale pour le fou la
grande diagonale
voilà une idée possible pour y boire une
idée de plan évidemment quatre c4 un
rôle ainsi il a joué il a joué alors il
a joué fou c4 je veux revenir
alors après il faut prendre trois j'en
prends un f3 kbc 6 fou c4
[Musique]
voilà fossé cadre donc ça c'est un coup
agressif ça attaque que l'option 9,7
ici ça peut avoir un rôle dans certaines
certaines possibilités
qu'est ce qui se passe sur plus grand
des quatre alors maintenant qu'il est
noir que vous rejouez effectivement ça
n'empêche pas comprendre les 4g me
lavant qui comprend d'apprendre et 2
d'emprunt des deux là après on reprend
l'air bien mais si deux prises possible
plutôt qu'à vallée prend plutôt qu'à
vallée prend ici avec la menace car les
pointes 3 qui gagne on est noir en
récupérer leurs tueurs mais les blancs
la paire de fou il n'a peut-être pas
peur chronique d'avoir une structure
moins bien oui mais l'avenir de fou je
vous trouve un couple a déjà tout d'un
coup volé blanc peut-être trois quarts
oui j'aime pas trop ça mais les trois
dates n'ont pas l'air très très gênant
mais sur f3 f4 les je pense qu'à et noir
n'ont pas de problème il peut même jouer
au 6 6 6 8 petits roquets ouais ça a
l'air tranquille et puis du nord vont
avoir un tueur f4 qui est faible donc
voilà une possibilité pour les noirs
donc tu as prévu krainik très curieux
sur pu emprunter 4 voilà pour les
stalles imposition et comme ça je me
prends des quatre il a joué non et
surtout prendre en france est vraiment
ridicule non mais plus on prend on
obligé de certains on prend et ça change
tout et là tu as pas en fait à le
récupérer un pied au centre là faut dire
mais ça doit pas être si simple si les
juifs ou sekkat aussi rapidement c'est
que y'a un truc la ville quelque chose
dans ses membres à ce qu'il ne pourrait
pas jouer un coup peut-être
intermédiaire c'est pas maintenant mais
il n'est pas pas comprendre tu me prends
alors quand même obligatoire d'aprr en
d2 reprend des deux les cavaliers prend
des 4 c'est la position critique
on peut le dire prenez 4 d'apprendre et
2 reprend d2 et qu'elle allait prendre
les quatre c'est la position à laquelle
doit réfléchir
garry kasparov actuellement
lorsqu'on peut avoir un plat on peut
être sûr sur gary en train de réfléchir
voilà
au plan de profil
voilà un plan de face aux dérives du
sport on se pose la question sur la
variante que l'on vienne le site et
voilà munich toujours debout chroniqué
dans son dans sa loge évidemment il peut
voir la partie sur l'échiquier vidéo
donc il peut voir la partie en direct
dès que kasparov à jour il est au
courant et il revient il peut revenir la
table alors pourquoi robert les joueurs
ne restent pas sur la table est ce que
c'est pour ne pas être en face de
l'adversaire est ce que c'est moins
agréable que oui mais ce cd ça dépend du
style le joueur de toute manière les
airs les russes c'est bien connu
regarde souvent en l'air pour calculer
les variantes donc ça les dérange pas de
ne pas être devant l'échec et pour
calculer leurs variantes est bon je
pense que dans la loge c'est plus
agréable de ils sont tranquilles ils
peuvent réfléchir comme il le souhaite
je sais pas c'est vraiment ça dépend du
style le joueur parce qu'on reste pas
avoir une partie nulle orapi novembre je
sais pas moi je suis en train de
regarder la variante en ce moment donc
comprend des quatre pions prendre d'un
dea de droit des deux cas et des cats et
un coup comme par exemple tour à b1
je sais pas
trois d un courage bien pendant projeter
un bon gâteau qui joue pas maintenant
bien les temps les noirs ne peuvent pas
ok la cause de tourcoing 7
mais bon une petite pression blanche
quand même on laisse le pion en f3 en
l'air mais c'est pas très très important
donc alors on va revenir sur l'échiquier
de démonstration pour montrer cette
variante donc là ici la position est
comme ça au départ donc là les noirs
pourrait jouer puis on prend des 4 puis
on prend des quatre d'en prendre des
deux on va prendre les deux cas les
prendre et 4 et la robert tu proposes to
crash berne mais en activant la pièce on
laisse le pion f3 emprise cercle
cavaliers en déca peu près 9 3 sur échec
conviendrait ou avec le roi on s'est
probablement ou à eux deux 1 2 le car il
pourrait revenir en d4 avec échec
oui c'est vrai mais mon nom sous des
quatre fous des cats mais non le
problème c'est que le fou le fond et
j'essaie de contrôler la tourache 8 ce
que par exemple probant de cadets 4 fou
prend cavaliers des fous prend tombé
huit échecs nommé nasri un psychiatre il
prend encore prendre 17 dont pour si je
vous le droit 17 tout de suite mais ne
savait pas le fou oui mais ça devient un
peu plus dangereux parce que maintenant
tour b 1b cet échec et je dessine enfin
les échecs qui peuvent être dangereux
donc là bon mais c'est peut-être une
position critique l'asca torv de
réfléchir je ne crois pas trop parce que
cavalier f3 et les cavaliers 5 par
exemple que ça va pas être ça peut être
ça qui crament nickel à vue dont
chronique a dû voir autre chose mais
c'était un fou point tu sais tu pourquoi
un
alors que propose de l'ordinateur dans
cette position weill propose puis on
prend des 4 et après et après puis on
prend des 4 on propose effectivement
c'est prendre des quatre d'apprendre et
de reprendre des deux quais les quatre
cavaliers des 4 et là il propose fou
prendre des quatre tout simplement fou
des 4 et voilà ce que propose
l'ordinateur ne cette variante il
propose vous prendrez 4
fou prend des 4
et effectivement maintenant deux tours
âge bien autour des 1
autour d une proposition
oui mais après six mois je vois pas je
vois pas où est davantage ou est
davantage selon le ciss faut 5 petit
rock qu'à mon avis c'est ouais
effectivement ça a pas l'air sa part
face à ce que leur ordinateur dans ces
genres de positions shebab
et oui il semblerait que la porte ici
est importé 1 et doit et loire où l'on
agisse y avait continué cette cette
partie merci stéphane alors nous allons
donc continuer à commenter cette partie
d'exception avec le jeune maître
champion de france junior en titre
robert fontaine qui a terminé je crois
cette année 10e ex-aequo aux
championnats de france toutes catégories
les sports robert devant toi je ne crois
pas mais en tout cas je crois que tu
étais plutôt derrière moi mais c'est pas
grave du tout oui je suis sûr que
j'avais un meilleur départ et j'avais le
meilleur des partages donc alors nous
pouvons continuer cram nick a pris la
paire de fous je sais pas ce que vous
étiez en train de dire en fait ça me
résumer un petit prêt mais on est en
train de dire on comprenait pas tout
d'abord pourquoi
kasparov a pris en f3 de khalis et 6
directement et maintenant longtemps on
est en train de chercher la variante
donc comprendre les 4 comprend des
cartes d'amd de roy d2 et qui avait les
prendre des quatre donc peut-être tu
peux récupérer psion pour bulgari dont
cramique ajoutons combien je m'étais
arrêté la suite à certains problèmes
techniques qui n'est que qui nécessitait
une assistance continue mais alors voilà
donc la position de démonstration
maintenant vous n'aurez plus de problème
si vous êtes connecté il y aura plus du
tout dedans nuit puisque tout a été
réglé par nos spécialistes depuis paris
donc pas de problème et si l'échiquier
de démonstration c'est la variante
simulés par robert fontaine et stéphane
laborde et ont détourné un coût proposé
par fritz mais sert
le couteau rien we go proposée par fritz
effectivement ici on pourrait dire que
les blancs et un petit avantage
puisqu'ils sont mieux développer et à
priori ne risque pas grand chose dans
cette position-là tour en bessette est
très active
mais est ce que est ce que les noirs et
ce quelque chose par exemple après au 6
avril place de foucauld f26 est floue et
sympathie rock faut 5 et petits roquets
alors qu'on a des aidants exemple avec
faut cinq et avec petit rock
effectivement ça ressemble à quelque
chose de très solides
est-ce qu'on ne risquerait pas par
exemple de se faire planter des fois ci
ça va mais ça amène un bateau protégé
plateau en a suite est protégé mais
alors ce qui est bizarre c'est que
cramique à jouer très rapidement tous
ces 4 1 donc il doit avoir prévu quelque
chose quoi une chronique et pour nous
préparer
si on peut avoir un bilan pendule grâce
à notre réalisation hors norme
c'est dire si les joueurs peuvent voir
la pendule sur l'échiquier de
démonstration avec à la réal
yannick qui assure un axe donc
effectivement nous avons acheté des
doses crise avec kasparov qui a réfléchi
une carte chine en 33 minutes et g nick
n'a fléchi que de 10000 donc
vraisemblablement robert travnik est
encore dans sa préparation
ouais je pense aux signaux wi a tué un
miraculeux devient un castor à la
pendule la pendule donc qui est là que
vous voyez est l instrument qui sert à
mesurer le temps 2h40 coup pour chacun
des joueurs pour le convier contrôle il
est maintenant si on peut avoir le plan
sur kasparov qui était totalement
fantastique
alors il va arriver le voilà à
l'enseigné kasparov est revenu dans une
pause de réflexion plus saines toi tu
connais bien d'irritation je crois qu'il
était sont ajoutés à l'université de
megève
oui tout à fait et juillet il était
passé un court nous montrer un peu ce
qu'ils savaient faire
eh oui si l'état il était vraiment très
impressionnant a baigné encore il est
n'est encore vraiment line et de
montceau castor il est bon quand il
réfléchit il faut bien faut bien le dire
alors bon on va revenir à la position
dans quelques instants
pour l'instant on se regarde cette image
de kasparov non maintenant revenons tout
de suite à l'opposition alors si c'est
comme ça d'accord voilà il a l'air
perplexe
c'est cette position-là fous ces
canadiens des jouets si je ne fais pas
d'erreur tout à fait et ici des joueurs
donc garry kasparov le joueur du
millénaire est en train de réfléchir
alors qu'est ce que tu en penses après
alors c'est qu'il faut voir plusieurs
possibilités donc en fait ce qui était
jouée à 17h37 le cavalier sortie en c6
et g league est souvent extravagants des
fonds étrangers pour le croate s'est
cassé six ou sept positions très
compliqué qu'est ce qu'on peut dire mais
pour l'instant l'option des quatre est
immobile et le pion aux quatre également
donc le centre l'endocrâne ni pour
l'instant est immobilisé il peut quand
même jouer eux 5 h 25
on peut jouer à 5 pour limiter l'action
du fou g7
ces salles avantages d'un centre avec
d'options c'est qu'on peut avancer suite
qu'on veut et ici on peut jouer au
ping-pong peut-être au programme mon
peut analyser la position des rois
c'est le premier facteur donc
apparemment le roi danse donc un peu
plus en danger que l'or noir est ce
qu'après petit rock vraisemblablement le
roi noir est bien entouré avec un fouet
tranquillement devant lui alors qu'en
revanche les blancs après petit rock
n'ont pas de pions et pas de fous devant
le roi et ce qui n'est pas du tout la
même chose ici
alors qu'est-ce que peut envisager garry
kasparov dans cette position kelkoo est
il en train de regarder donc pour
prendre des captures par des cadres d'un
pro d2 c'est la première chose à
laquelle on pense qu'ils semblent
effectivement si on suit notre analyse
précédente
ils sont menés à la nul qui son salaire
forêt alors là on voit kasparov
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut on peut
quand même essayer de lire sur son
visage est ce qu il en train de se dire
bon ben là je peux faire nul je peux le
faire je n'ai plus qu'à jouer mes coups
mais j'ai dit tu penses je peux
peut-être faire mieux non à mon avis
c'est pas ça avant mais on est en train
de séduire par les risques qu est-ce qui
la prépare puisque fou c4 seulement 10
minutes de réflexion et encore il a dû
réfléchir de trois minutes pour je
tousse et 4 il doit se poser des
questions ce qu'ils pouvaient jouer aux
cinq tout simplement à la plage de
sousse et 4 et vont essayer de conserver
son clan des 80 mais là ils le donnent
vraiment quasiment un tempo ils le
donnent volontairement et quelle qu'elle
soit peut dire peut-être un coup comme
tour des huit mois autour des luttes ne
sert à rien on tout à fait effectivement
le coup critique c'est champion des cas
dit il
alors bon qu'elle corresponde ou petit à
petit rock en fait alors éventuellement
est-ce qu'on peut envisager que castor
se disent je suis mieux je vais jouer
pour l'initiative pour la vente âge oui
bien sûr on peut l'envisager envisageant
l'eau alors un petit regret que quatre
ans ne veut pas fermer
de toute façon c'est une des questions
qu on leur posera la conférence de
presse qui va suivre
donc voilà garry kasparov a joué petit
rock et bien entendu nos guides mandron
pourquoi il
jouer ses 34 sur quoi bien entendu
kasparov ne répondra pas puisqu'il ne
veut pas dévoiler de d'éléments sur les
ouvertures donc là nous avons une chaise
vide
personne dans l'intervalle thater de
choc voilà avec la montre de kasparov
si vous pouvez la voir qui est en moi
voilà la scène décors de télévision nous
sommes sur un plateau de télé à rivers a
su durant direct de londres
et ici personne n'est là personne ne l'a
tout simplement fauteuils en cuir pour
chronique photo médiévale pour kasparov
voilà kramnik revient et il va donc
est-ce qu'il va jouer tel pot à ton avis
on verra ce qu'il va jouer demain je
pense qu'un an
non il va réfléchir un petit rôle ouais
moi je ne pense pas que petit rock ait
pu surprendre dernière fabrique je ne
pense pas à mon avis g va jouer
rapidement ici est une gaffe ils vont le
savoir dans quelques instants
mais que peut-il jouer donc voilà c'est
une question qui mérite d'être posée est
ce qui fait défaut en option des quatre
il peut jouer encore quatre ou cinq
oui alors sur 4,5 probablement kasparov
jouera tous rêvent des huit tours à des
huit je ne sais pas laquelle donc le 4 5
donc petit rock mais très bien entendu
une tous rendez vite petit rock
s'accroît quand même la pression sur sur
le centre et blanc oui les petits rock
que peut espérer où il peut être que
pour les noirs tu venir ici dans cette
position on a quand même le sentiment
que
que kasparov et tranquille 14 malades
surtout qu'on n'a pas trouvé ce qui ce
qui allait pas après pions prendre mes
catala plateau petits roms a déjà donc
l'un qui tels que tu as raison ils
recherchent mieux qu'un nul mais dans
notre côté est ce qu'on peut envisager
avec un joueur du calibre de la douleur
chronique puisse être mal au douzième
coup avec le nom dans un match de
championnat du monde sur une ouverture
attendue surtout avec dix minutes
seulement de réflexion avec des buts de
réflexion c'est pas possible tout
simplement donc ici cramique a vu plus
loin c'est un peu ce qu'on avait comme
sentiment signé en commentant avec
stéphane laborde
c'était tout simplement que chaque fois
qu'un joueur je vois un coup on pensait
qu'ils étaient mieux ici raconte ans que
kasparov et mieux d'être cramatte à
jouer peut-être pas mieux mais et
beaucoup de jeu point le pian quand même
mais bon t'as raison c'est une âme et
diaby a également la peur de tout aussi
obligé alors le problème c'est que le
crâne était très friand des attaques sur
le roi mais ici kasparov peut échanger
les dames quand il veut donc il ya même
pas à se poser le problème de l est ce
qu on peut l'attaquer ou quoi donc ici
aux 4/5 y retourner vite tout simplement
grosse initiatives pour garry kasparov
écrin unique qui réfléchit ça c'est très
très mauvais signe pour lui alors je ne
sais pas c'est qu'à ce moment fait tapis
dans l'ombre comme hier en tout cas
ce n'est pas pas une chose évidente on
va peut-être avoir quelques plans pour
voir si kasparov et par là ou si nous
n'en avons pas nous débuterons qu'il
n'est pas là tout simplement
donc ici voilà tranquillou nous
continuerons ce direct
garry kasparov la lumière fabriqués dans
cette position nous avons le sentiment
que le champion du monde serait
peut-être mieux un peu mieux un petit
peu mieux la dire chronique concentré
dans quel sport n'est pas là il est dans
sa loge il regarde probablement la
position il est en train de boire il ya
du coca il ya de l'eau aussi donc
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait dès mars
également il peut manger à peu près ce
qu'il veut donc revenons à la position
puisque là il faut absolument en savoir
plus envisager toutes les possibilités
de la dynamique
quel est son problème dans l'opposition
c'est le pion des quatre alors comment
reconception des cas alors il peut il
peut jouer ou 5 ce qui semble nous
allons regarder en direct un coup
critique une possibilité vladimir
kramnik jour et de 4,5 sur quoi deux
possibilités pour kasparov soit il mento
en débit soit en bibitte
oui j'opterais plutôt pour tous rêvent
dé 8 mai tous rêvent d huile menace en
me menaçant cavaliers 5 par exemple way
to have d'élite mais là alors réputation
que ta part
le coup au 5 e 6 donc puisque kasparov
n'a plus de foot canne blanche
effectivement on peut commencer à
envisager déjà le 6 par exemple f 5
l/100 coupions 36 noms qui comprend en
souffrent et qui entreprend un rouage
suite par exemple
c'est une possibilité nous vous montrons
évidemment ce n'est pas jouer dans ce
match kasparov qu'un mini rond a fuité
ici on a quand même le sentiment que
cette position est très très bonne pour
les noirs oui tout à fait en fait la
structure - chez vraiment cassé donc si
nous revenons après le 14e coupe
possible de vladimir kramnik 4,5 s'est
permis un petit rock kremnica jouer
petit rock
donc nous allons tout de suite mentionné
ce coup petit roquet a été jouée par
donc là il laisse vraiment délibérément
le pion des cats on trees l'absurde et
iv étant prises complètement
alors est-ce que tu termines casper
quelque chose avec la paire de fois la
fin alors est-ce qu'on va pas assister
une fois plus avec nous le rapide c'est
possible c'est possible psychologie de
marche
robert je crois que tu as joué des
matches déjà non non robert n'a pas joué
de match donc on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas trop si moi je pense que les joueurs
ont envie de se mettre en train de
rappel de testa rossa dans 80 fr vous
avez commencé par minute donc c'est
possible et il essaie de se tester un
peu il évalue un peu leur préparation
théorique chacun est bon là ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'elles ont une menace
mona se jouer des quatre dessins de ça
paraît assez clair mais moi ce qui me
surprend c'est que chrome nickel utilisé
seulement
quatorze minutes c'est pour pour avoir
une position quasiment égale quoi si la
position et eliane donc ça ça me
surprend un peu quand même donc ici nous
sommes sur le shit et de démonstrations
la menace blanche cédé 4 des 5
ouais avec l'option c5 qui sera prise à
part le foot est roi et simplement les
noirs ministre ait un peu pris le
contrôle depuis ce que je lui aurais
conserver tout le potentiel de leur
centre tout à fait donc ici
vraisemblablement garry kasparov alloué
qu'un point d'écart sur quoi que peut
jouer vladimir kramnik à part prendre du
plomb du pion on ne sait pas a priori
ses forces et puis on prend pions
kasparov ici doit jouer d'un programme
il peut également envisager fou prend
des quatre qui pourrait prendre quatre à
l'air moins fort à présent que c'est une
possibilité également donc bon peut-être
que quelques grammes nick évalue cette
position comme légèrement un peu mieux
pour lui quand même ce qu'il à la paire
de fou le pion à 6 c'est peut-être le
pion à 6 est un peu faible ouais ouais
ça doit être ça line et ça doit être ça
dd et on veut jouer cette position sans
risque s'il n'a pas envie de perdre une
partie dès le début du match c'est oui
d'un autre côté contre conscience si on
commence à essayer d'aller marquer des
points avec les blancs ce n'est pas avec
ça mais ça va pas être facile pour
l'assiette un autre ici et là ça y est
ça l est les nuls de kasparov
qu'est-ce qui a pas ce qu'est ce qu'il
veut je comprends pas cram nick tu joues
n'importe quoi tu fais rire voilà c'est
exactement ce que ça te pètes votre
série glee c'est tout gary concentré
roya rien
je vais bientôt proposer mieux alors en
général quand il fait cette tête là il
ya un petit jeu qui s'instaure entre
vladimir kramnik et 40 castrophe c'est
qui va proposer mieux alors kasparov
avec césaire dubitatif oula oula
il incite vraiment ramic a proposé lui
un plan serré très bon plan de notre
réalisateur choc superbe expérience qui
ne comprend pas ce qu'est enfin de se
passer c'est superbe c'est superbe c'est
des superbes images voilà il est là il
n'hésite pas à mon sens peut-être une
pointe
il ya peut-être commencer à sentir
l'idée l'allemagne alors revenons sur
l'échiquier démonstration puisque nous
sommes dans la merde critique qui a
l'air à peu près forcé ici nous allons
envisager dans un premier temps de jeu
d'un programme nous verrons foot rendre
après faut prendre la main et maintenant
que peut tirer là c'est alors qu'il
semblerait les quatre que un nouveau
commentateur soit arrivé et donc en fait
c'était une illusion d'optique car ici
nous continuons fournée de là il faut
prendre l'option des quatre cavalières
ont un coeur énorme non posée par robert
oui tout à fait c'est très logique
normalement on jouerait rejet de sa part
est tout à fait normal et donc
évaluation de cette position qu'est ce
qu'on peut en dire le pion aux 7 est en
prise ces barèmes la tourbe et cette
attaque ce pion au cem le fou c4 garde
un oeil sur le pion à 6 c'est une chose
importante est là peut-être problème
pour y être un peu mieux pour les blancs
quand même a priori le coup dans cette
mission c'est de 7,6 très logique pour
lutter justement contrefoutent quatre
ans qu il y ait maintenant on peut se
demander ce qui se passerait c'est pas
de faire du tout mais effectivement
avantage blanc et chroniques adore
proprement ce genre de position
puisqu'ils peuvent y c'est simplement
on allait il y fait de la série d une
faiblesse via la paire de fou il ya des
belles perspectives pour les blancs donc
revenons une fois plus c'est l'effet
comique joue petit rock et on pense tout
de suite qu'il est mieux c'est normal le
temps que kasparov trouve quelque chose
donc nous sommes dans la position réelle
actuellement nous allons enlever les
flèches mais un peu de nettoyage alarme
la position actuelle de ce match avec un
cast a rohff qui réfléchit toujours mal
autant qu'elle soit on va sauter dominer
autant c'est clairement de main de temps
aucun doute qu'en dit connaît cette
position il a regardé avec ses sodas non
alors il m'a semblé en venant la salle
ce matin voies nouvelles idées ska dans
un taxi mais peut-être on ne peut pas
savoir ce qui se passe à londres
en tout cas vraisemblablement cramique
essaie de cacher ses seconds ans on en
connaît un vrai j'en connais bien
demandé qu'on connaît donc il s'agit
déjà de l'hôte et effectivement le
meilleur joueur français
askarov voûté sur l'échiquier concentré
alors peut-être que jsk asselah il
escales sur le court est un spécialiste
de la greffe elle a confirmé groenefeld
6 nov
c'est possible on ces deux ouvertures de
prédilection je mal lotis évidemment il
est très très bien préparée contre la
drogue elle est de l'avenir qu'indique
est un spécialiste mondial
un tueur de compte fait comme on les
appelle john falck et l'ouverture que
kaspar vient d'utiliser f alors ici 26 g
nick va chercher kasparov sur son
terrain quand même elle est l'entrée
dans la green fade
inversement les formes mais recherché
candide sur son terrain aussi en fait
les deux jours de recherches les castors
aucun problème avec c'est tout le sens
du show biz hariri
un problème avec ça c'est indiscutable
voilà le problème a été résolu
rapidement par le champion du monde
depuis plus de 15 ans heureusement la
position de la position la voilà la
position superbe position ici garde t
sport va jouer ces grands des cas c'est
pratiquement une certitude ce surcoût
entre amis tu répondras par comprendre
hélas l'autre coup possible reprend les
quatre ans des quatre il paraît plus
logique puisque on a quand même envie
d'échanger un fou pour lutter contre la
paire de fou donc damas cinq cavaliers à
cinq voix la surnomme 35.5 attaque
la taxe est alors on va là on va le
montrer puisque des 3,5 à priori est une
faute
il est prêté 3 5 le cavalier attaquera
en deux temps la tourbe et 7 et le fou
c'est capté ce qu'on appelle une fourche
à la fourchette
c'est à dire le nom vulgaire pour une
attaque double et venant de plus de
technique
ici pas de sacrifices possibles non ce
n'est pas bon
g nick ne jouera pas ça revenons à près
de [ __ ] en d4 il ne faut pas jouer
d'après à 5 voilà la position critique
puisque si on joue fou prend fou dans
cette position un petit problème la dame
des deux sera reprise on ne peut pas
jouer aux dames profond puisque le fou
est défendue par le caire et 10 et 6
c'est clair donc ici mon crâne munich
veut jouer un coucou simple par exemple
autour des 1 comme il peut jouer un
coussin par exemple tour des 1 est-ce
qu'on peut envisager sous dessins de
cautionner des cinq salles aimerait
maintenant il faut des 5
toujours prendre en d2 et jouer un dam
des deux fous des deux tours c'est 8
donnerait le pion aux 7 voilà voilà
voilà
avec l'idée de pilonner ce pion aux sept
sélections chasse le cavalier la tour b
7 viendrai ramasser le bureau set et
ensuite on attaque réelle 7 avec la tour
et le fou ça c'est pas acceptable
ici vraisemblablement le bon coup pour
les noirs ça serait dur pour eux trois
je vous prends un train alors attention
nous avons des nouvelles de l'extérieur
voilà 650 et le chiffre magique le
chiffre on s'approche de 666 le chiffre
du diable voilà donc 650
c'est le chiffre clef de ce moment alors
peu importe les chiffres nous voyons
plutôt la position fou dessin qui a été
joué non si descente n'a pas été c'est
une simulation ici de coups possibles
d'un pro d2 ou faux bond de 3 on
surprend et trois dames 33ème seul coup
franc droit d'un point 3 et forcé alors
allons-y
c'est une possibilité pour éliminer
justement la paire de fou d'un point 3
et maintenant a priori les blancs sont
beaucoup mieux sont beaucoup mieux
puisqu'il ya des problèmes pour les
noirs le prendre à maryse ollivier donc
ça c'est pas possible
après fou des cinq autres possibilités
d'un pro d2 allons-y pour ce coup il
faut être assez exhaustif sans être
technique sonné c'est pas un exercice
facile de commenter en direct un
championnat du monde fou prend des 2 2
et maintenant le coup probablement
cavaliers sur la case e 5 e et c'est
très chaud là c'est très chaud il ya des
complications l'ordinateur a l'air de
dire que c'est légal ouais on sait pas
pourquoi c'est l'ordinateur qui qui
évalue sa comme égal très aléatoire en
tout cas valu cinq way a priori une
certitude dans cette position les blancs
ont l'initiative donc finalement petit
rock c'est bien jaune c'est une
possibilité petit rock bien joué de la
part de venir
mais nous revenons sur la position plus
ou moins réels et maintenant une demi
heure d'avancé pour chronique voilà
chronique une demi heure d'avancé
effectivement c'est chaud pour gary non
c'est chaud pour garder jal hier a donné
l'impression se fait un peu vis et avec
les pièces blanches où on a l'impression
qu'il n'a pas réussi à s'en sortir et
aujourd'hui eh bien elle vient encore en
train de souffrir voilà la position
réelle donné un grand l'échiné des lost
boys à la première ronde on peut
supposer que kasparov a été surpris par
la berlinoise
mais ici il joue quand même la grogne
fel donc qui doit il doit bien connaître
cette ouverture donc c'est quand même un
peu plus surprenant aujourd'hui qu'ils
soient en retard au temps oui c'est à
dire que mentionné quelque chose aussi
c'est que les joueurs dans leur
préparation pour les ouvertures en
général ont tendance à blinder leur
répertoire côté noir cerclé noir comme
on bénéficie en fait on bénéficie d'un
désavantage le fait que les bleus jouent
en premier on a tendance à être beaucoup
plus pointue dans l'analyse des
variantes et ici il semblerait que trame
unique donc déjà bénéficié davantage une
trêve et en plus bénéficient davantage
de la préparation ça fait deux chaînes
ce qui est énorme pour un champion ce
qui est énorme il est tout à fait énorme
donc kasparov en difficulté je pense
qu'il faut le dire en tout cas kasparov
en difficulté jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
joué un coup et nous frapperons
retourner notre veste mais c'est très
très difficile si on était au niveau de
ces joueurs là eh bien nous serions en
train de les voir
oui donc ici puis on prend des 4 as
l'air quand même intéressant je prends
des quatre est quand même le coût
principal on peut supposer ici je prends
des cats est clairement compostage mais
alors à quoi pourrait fléchir garry
kasparov si ce n'est pas pour autant
d'écart puisque si c'était le coup
forcément ça fait alors il peut
peut-être réfléchir
est-ce que des 5e et des 5 es vraiment
une menace est ce que il peut laisser
pousser trois échoué non donc voyons une
autre possibilité qui serait un coup
naturel dans cette position tour eiffe
tour md 8 par exemple coûterait très
naturel tout va très vite
effectivement c'est vrai que c'est mieux
puisque c'est maintenant on vient
prendre en d4
eh bien on prendra ce non plus avec le
fou cavani qui sont pas très efficaces
mais avec la tour qui est quand même une
autre affaire dimensions dimension
exactement autour des 8 donc ici la
grande question c'est des cas le dessin
des cadets 5 fu des cinq a l'air un peu
ridicules en fout des 5 1 les cinq et
des factures et peut-être tu auras c8
tout simplement non 308 fou des saintes
c'est une possibilité mais c'est une
possibilité qui n'est pas positionnelle
tout à fait un professionnel puisque
après le fou n'est pas stable il ya le
coût 7 6 il ya par exemple sur food et 5
ans peut envisager puis on prenait 4 je
prends des cafres également avec
d'énormes problèmes pour les blancs donc
ici d4 d5 sicard et astor veut encore
améliorer ses pièces il se pose donc il
s'expose un gros problème c'est que les
blancs gardent leur potentiel centrale
donc là bien entendu l'option c3 est en
prise peut supposer que garmin va le
prendre et vous vous pensez devoir dame
ces deux par exemple d'accéder aux dames
de dames et de ça ne change pas vraiment
grand chose ça tacle cavaliers et
cavalières et 4 qui m'a dit viens en d4
et du jeu quand même pour les noirs il
faut prendre le cahier 4 hélas après
probablement fou prend des cabines plus
logique
les blancs ont quand même une initiative
puisque après tour bien contrôleront la
colonne b ouais mais initiative qui
n'est pas forcément suffisante
quoique légèrement mieux pour les blancs
des transitions pour les blancs donc ça
on va revenir encore une fois sur cette
variante tout rêve des vides pour
améliorer mon tour mettre plus de
pression au centre
ouais d4 d5 foot français 3 peut-être
que la caf c2 a été mal choisi ça c'est
une possible annonce puisque les blancs
sont contents donc on ne va pas essayer
d'améliorer les coudes et blanc ouais
dames c'est le même ses doigts il ya
peut-être cavaliers au simple aussi nul
possible qu'avec le 5-fu de maintenant
et blanc conservent leur père de fou et
on le centre voyais tout à fait menace
de chasser le cavalier part peut-être
f2f car f3 f4 pendant que le 5-fu 2
voilà avec l'idée f3 f4 là les blancs
sont clairement une position difficile
pour la peau garry kasparov qui a
réfléchi
donc revenons à la position actuelle on
va revoir mentionné rapidement les deux
possibilités qu'on a trouvé un petit
regret bladinières ramener la première
session prend des cats qui conduit à une
finale légèrement inférieur ouais la
deuxième c'est tout rêve des huit qui
amène une position plus mauvaise oui
donc comprend écarté du coup là et puis
reprend des quatre salles avec le coup
est ce qu'on peut envisager tourbe évite
aussi ça son village ou comme ça tout à
fait tomber il semble assez logique
on n'est pas obligé à deux choix ou tour
ou tourbe et un autre pan des huit tours
prend des buts a l'air plus logique
quand même tombe bien c'est possible
aussi mes torts bien c'est possible
embellie bref format cd doit être
possible peut-être davantage de tout
reprendre et vite c'est que ça sera à
nous de jouer après donc un lien temps
et noir reprennent et maintenant on peut
encore envisager des quatre des cinq et
on peut aussi envisager où ils coupent
proposé par fritz qui a l'air très bons
donc fritz et notre ordinateur de bord
c'est le coutour d1 qui garde l'option
des quatre qui a les reins est ce que
est ce que c'est si fort que ça après pu
comprendre les quatre dans une puis on
prend des 4 par exemple si on profite à
lyon 34 dame prend des deux donc d'un
prend des deux tours en d2 qui est
l'idée de tourner un don en d2 un loyer
tour b 4 alors là effectivement les
blancs ont quand même une très belle
position puisqu'ils ont autant plus
quand ils peuvent prendre le pion à 6
garder un ton plus il ya un délateur de
fou garder on fait tous leurs avantages
donc ça c'est pas une bonne option pour
les noirs c'est clair revenons à la
pensée y ait beaucoup d'analystes
beaucoup d'analystes heroes petit rock
et garry kasparov entrant à bas la voilà
c'est le moment de l'agrandir
agrandissons garry kasparov pour le voir
en géant voilà la réal la real s'était
momentanément relâchés mais nous sommes
tout de suite de retour sur un gros plan
de garry kasparov
voilà qui est très concentré qui a l'air
heureux comme d'avoir trouvé des
solutions
moi je dirais qu'il avait beaucoup plus
souvent qu'avant oui mais au fur et à
mesure que le temps passe il calcule
énormément de variantes donc oui il doit
avoir trouvé quelque chose à mon avis
quand même on voit pas on le voit pas si
nerveux que on l'a vu faire des miracles
tout à l'heure il en fait encore mais
j'ai vu le reportage qui est passé sur
france 3 et quelques jours et on a vu
tout l'expression toutes les expressions
qui qu'il peut faire prendre une partie
c'est quand même assez impressionnant
est ici ici c'est encore ce encore
normal on va dire pour lui donc on va
faire mal
une des scènes des scènes vraiment
d'anthologie de garry kasparov
on a vu d'ailleurs krainik dire qu'il
n'avait pas de qui n'avait pas peur de
tout ses mimiques
oui oui mais non mais c'est vrai que si
on commence à avoir peur des mimiques de
kasparov
c'est fini on est mal fait mal parce
qu'il en fait quand même un maximum donc
la voie ya toujours ce décor voir cette
vidéo garry kasparov n'attendent hull et
catastrophe
une fois de plus 40 minutes de retard
impressionnant ça commence à faire
beaucoup
il faut bosser une mauvaise habitude
pour 40 minutes et on est seulement 14e
coup ce qui veut dire qu'il reste donc
quelques espérant une recette pour jouer
un petit coup si nous fait une moyenne
d'un peu plus de deux minutes parcours
fort même 2 minutes 20 précisément je
vous
parra vérifier que ce spectacle tient
aucun intérêt tout simplement mais
kasparov quand même montre ses limites
puisque je pense que les dix premiers
coups nous a joué très vite qu'ils
connaissent des regards que c'est là le
moment où il ne connaît plus c'est
possible puisque on s'était joueurs
évidemment une panoplie de variantes à
leur disposition moi je ne connais pas
du tout cette vente et ont peut-être
qu'il ya une nouveauté une nouveauté
importante
on vérifiera effet entendu dans le
résumé ce soir puisque évidemment après
la partie en direct ça ça le direct
continue ne s'arrête pas sera suivie par
la conférence de presse en présence de
casques portés par nick ensuite le
résumé par dai qing et rémy keane en
anglais et ensuite le résumé en français
par robert fontaine stéphane laborde et
moi en tout cas deux parmi 3 à un stress
donc cyclonique a décidé de jouer cette
partie est pas fait un nul rapidement ça
risque d'être intéressant quand même
cette position même paraît légèrement
mieux pour les blancs une chose avec 40
minutes d'avancé
c'est vraiment j'aurais chronique ne
fera pas nulles si les news c'est pas
une bonne stratégie dans un match ça
part et ça paraît assez clair tigre
l'ogre de bakou réfléchi mais vraiment
très très tendue il est vraiment très
tendue la montre alors oui peut-être pas
fait sponsoriser par sa non c'est à dire
il c'est une société de montres suisses
donc avec qui a vu des fameuses limite
de kasparov qui le fameux rituel en
début de phase et ça montre ses seins
desserrer la cravate
tout s'est un petit peu et poser la
montre très excité quand ils ont vu ça
et aujourd'hui à gary et bien voilà nous
te fournit sont en montre peut-être
mérité des accords financiers derrière
et en échange tu continues à faire ça
avec notre monde effectué ça marche
c'est un mille comme michael jordan qui
met des nike ibérique restaurant mais
des montres suisses c'est pas le même
le même score il réfléchit à fléchir
réfléchit donc oui que prendre les
cartes puis on prend les quatre quand
même à l'heure le coût croissant c'est
puis on prend des quatre pions grande et
4 alors nous allons bientôt venir passer
le thème des deux allait la position a
l'air normal
voilà la position actuelle alors
peut-être la meilleure chance de
kasparov et de rentrer dans cette finale
légèrement inférieurs parce que même si
cram nick a une grosse technique en
finale kasparov les parents possèdent
que possèdent une
je pense qu'il est pas mal non plus
quatre portes est pas mal donc elle
reste un joueur très complet
donc effectivement nous avons la
pression devant les yeux et pour
l'instant l'analyse donc de nous mêmes
c'est à dire et loire revanche pour moi
et robert compte est pour mon compagnon
de travail un grand maître est un maître
international
c'est que t'es sport va jouer qu un
point d 4d nationale ans d'écart il faut
prier pour qu'ils jouent ça allait
prendre une carte mais effectivement fou
prend des cas tu penses moi je pense
plutôt à dame prenait 2 est rentré dans
cette finale alors inférieur
souffrant des cats on a vu que ça l'est
c'est quand même un bon avantage pour
l'avs lancé dans le courant des deux
fours en d2 et maintenant il faut
prendre en déca oui avec le
rassemblement lecavalier
oui ou c'est non
et après roy g2 est bien là et là il de
l'accusation et dwan analysé je pense à
cette acquisition fait ici c'est le coup
et hausse est aussi vraisemblablement
par exemple et maintenant c'est là que
c'est là que ça commence à être chaud
c'est peut-être je trie celui-là blé
kasparov entendu kasparov a vu cette
position
ça n'a pas pu lui échapper il est en
train de comparer avec d'autres
positions mais là il est en train de
réfléchir comique n'est pas là on peut
voilà on peut voir ça sur le plan
dramatique joue son coup et soulève tout
de suite comme unique jeu et s'en va
aller tout à fait c'est une c'est
peut-être une technique psychologique
pour dire la casse port bouet écoute des
bruits réfléchi mon lapin la tâche parce
que je sais déjà très bien ce qui est en
train de se passer
donc tout est prévu fatigue dois vous
dire que je reviendrai quand j'aurai
envie
donc c'est possible rebond la position
quand même puisque cette position après
après que ceux ci on va peut-être là
détaillé
parce que ça intéresse corrélant
peut-être les internautes alors la
tournée en f1 ne joue pas donc il serait
logique de la m soit en d1 soit en b1 je
sais pas où exactement
en d1 ou un bien sûr une des deux cases
et des colonnes a ouvert le feu en d2 et
pas spécialement actifs
oui je vois pas trop comment peut
l'améliorer a oui on peut envisager de
peut-être de passer par non non non pour
envisager d'ordonner un fou et 3 à l'air
logique mais est ce que c'est vraiment
est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer d une
action rapide contre le pion à 6 comme
tombé 6 par exemple tomber si c'est très
rapide peut-être trop peut-être trop
radio non d'abord un bond à vie de chat
dit qu'avant de avant d'attaquer il
fallait bloquer donc x 5 x 5 spécialités
jaurès et la malice et altéré mais on
peut essayer de limiter l'action de ce
cavalier alors il ya un compositionnel
dans cette position peut-être aubert
c'est beaucoup f k way pour jouer aux
cinq qui permettrait d'en fermer le fou
g7 est de fixer les pions noirs sur
cases blanches qui est quand même
l'avenir est sorti est intéressant mais
ça te perdrait la case f5 le contrôle de
cette cave pour le cavalier à ses clés
alors nous avons probablement stéphane
laborde qui va revenir aux commentaires
d'ailleurs puisque puisqu'il est très
chaud donc voilà stéphane laborde le
retour il va commenter avec robert
fontaine pendant quelques minutes encore
et ensuite je remplacerais robert
fontaine
ok voilà donc alors cette position et a
dû n'a pas échappé à garry kasparov au
f4 f4 moi je n'aime pas trop ce coup je
préférais quand même placé la tour en
france sur une case active et est active
et ainsi la dernière pièce pièce blanche
alors voilà heureusement droit d'israël
avance trois quarts d'heure d'avancé
pour krainik ça commence à être assez
conséquent quand même surtout après
quatorze coups joués il réfléchit
beaucoup donc là
granic est toujours tragique qui en
avance considérable ont fait autant
kasparov s'est décidément ça fait deux
fois mais là c'est plus grave parce que
peut-être on va revenir à l'échiquier
réel parce que jérôme maître et position
parce que l'on s'est un peu éloigné
alors 45 minutes de retard sur une
position légèrement inférieur ça sent
pas très bon pour garry kasparov quand
même alors vous vivez avec les lois que
les légèrement inférieur donc sept mois
on a regardé principalement la finale
âpre et puis on prend des cats et celui
de l'échangé dames et on pense que les
blancs sont légèrement mieux
c'est grâce à la paire de fouet au pion
à six qui est faible donc là kasparov et
à la mousse c'est c'est possible mais je
alors là est-ce que cramique pour jouer
45 minutes pile voilà un plan à base de
éventuellement des cinq pour le seul
pion c3 et reprendre le pion aux 7
alors ça serait parfait mais c'est
autant de jouer donc si c'était au blanc
évidemment des 5
ouais c'est vrai très fort donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut absolument empêcher
ce coup par soit tour des huit qui font
des salaires des 5 ans et alors tous les
5 intéressant aussi pour faire une
pression sur sept alors toujours en
pleine concentration qui comprend des
cartes à l'air le coup principe a l'air
d'être le coût principal
alors comment kasparov à petit et
réfléchir on se met dans des situations
pareilles mais craint munich est tout
simplement mieux préparés ils avaient
prévu ça avant la partie kasparov
peut-être pas il faut rappeler puisqu'on
parle préparation que je jouais lautier
et régis des grammy qu'à se préparer
oui il est le second dans et les seconds
hand kramnik et il doit y en avoir
beaucoup d'autres amendes avignon
donnez-leur d'autres mais je vais le
dise particulier parce que mon abordant
un autre numéro un national
et puis aussi c'est un des rares joueurs
au monde avec positif comme kasparov
tout à fait donc il sait comment le
battre
il sait comment le battre et pour
l'instant ça porte ses fruits
mais bon encore un bon choix un bon
choix d'ouverture pour kramnik réfléchit
encore j'ai fait un semi rapides à
bruxelles ce week-end il y avait peter
spuhler qui connaît assez bien à
blaziert kramnik et géomatique aux
parents aussi qui a battu kasparov et je
lui ai demandé ce qu'ils pensaient de ce
match dont une qui me disait que
kasparov était quand même un peu favori
mais que krainik à les indés varier
énormément ces ouvertures et essayer de
surprendre kasparov donc il avait tout à
fait raison et on peut s'apercevoir que
pour l'instant ça marche puisqu'il a
plus de trois quarts d'heure à la
pendule ou et contrairement à hier où
c'était une position de blocus ou
kasparov les dimanches pardon au
classement fo a pu bloquer la position
relativement facilement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas si un
noir donc s'il continue à perdre du
temps comme ça on en est qu'au 14e coup
il reste moins d'une heure en erreur
donc ça fait six heures trente minutes
pour 26 coups oui deux minutes comme
indiqué par quoi devrait donc s'il
trouve pas une variante pour annuler
pour essayer d'annuler rapidement ça va
devenir très critique pour l'union on va
noter le thème code actuel
on va essayer de faire de plans sur
kasparov
réfléchis toujours je sais pas voilà là
il doit se rendre compte qu'il est un
peu moins bien quand même maintenant ça
doit être quasiment sûr à moins qu'il
calcule une variante très longue où il
voit déjà des possibilités d'agnelet
mais bon ça n'aurait pas en or or
préparation là c'est sûr à 100% une
heure une heure de réflexion pour 14
coup c'est sûr et certain
par contre comme nick lui doit être
encore dans sa préparation aux
catastrophes la fiq hâtives et encore
une fois il a fait c'est ce qui vient
les kasparov c'est qu'on voit tout de
suite on va tout de suite s'il est bien
ou pas ouais il suffit de regarder sa
tête et c'est un général pas du bluff
quand il est bien ça doit aussi y la
1ère un petit peu condescendant sur
l'adversaire nous comme si les mâles
unis fed et non de la tête
sinon voilà à nerveux harry est nerveuse
kasparov excellent plan là il habille
défendu il est en u ou alors ils voient
que la finale il peut obtenir une finale
légèrement inférieur et ils n'aiment pas
ça puisque lui on sait qu'ils
recherchent toujours de l'activité en
voirie ps on va revenir les flics et de
démonstration pour rappeler que le coup
ici principal est le pion c5 qui prend
l'option des quatre avait des échanges
au centre mais l'élan puis on prend des
quatre voilà les blues se retrouvant à
une finale légèrement supérieure avec
deux fous surtout c'est ça surtout ça de
fou et le plus ainsi ce qui est faible
voix le pion à 6 on va le montrer ici ce
pion à 6 sur lequel table le fou c4
voilà le fond ces quatre tables sur ce
pion mais il manque qu on s'aperçoit
donc le fou de cases blanches pour les
noirs ce qui peut compliquer la tâche de
kasparov dans cette finale voilà on va
revenir au plan large c'était juste pour
appeler les les idées
kasparov en difficulté alors on va noter
ici que cramique n'est pas là il n'est
pas là depuis au moins un bon quart
d'heure ouais donc il doit vraiment être
confiant plus pentue que voir la chaise
vide
je crains voilà c'est toujours il
regarde sa pendule c'était remarquable
de voir le alors là le temps réel 50
minutes c'est une norme il ya 55 minutes
kasparov il lui restait alors je
rappelle le temps on va rappeler les
règles de temps robert wilson pourtant
pour les gens qui fait découvrir le jeu
d'échecs aujourd'hui dont ils ont deux
heures chacun pour atteindre 40 pour
atteindre 40 coups tout à fait
donc ça veut dire si ils arrivent au 35e
coûts et par exemple kasparov s'il
arrive au 35e couilles qui il arrive à
zéro sur sa pente bull qu'est-ce qui se
passe il arrive à zéro il a perdu la
partie quoi qu'il arrive même s'il est à
un coup du un coup de fermes at il a
perdu voilà donc il faut absolument
qu'ils jouent ses coûts dans les deux
heures imparties tout à fait alors s'il
arrive au 40e coup ensuite il ya une
espèce de prolongation c'est à dire que
chaque chaque joueur a une heure pour
effectuer 20 coups donc on rajoute une
heure cet art si on a un capital temps
qu'on a préservé par exemple le site
ramic joue ses 40 coups en 1h30
il reste trente minutes au 40e coup on
lui rajoute une heure ils leur donnent
une âme errante pour les prochains pour
les 20 prochains coups pour aller
jusqu'au 60e coup et ensuite il leur
reste à en gros on va simplifier parce
qu'il ya des seconds additionnel par
coup pour pas pour profiter de problème
mais grosso modo ils ont trente minutes
au delà du soixantième coup on leur
rajoute 30 minutes de temps et là il
faut garder la porte absolument non mais
c'est quand même rarissime à ce niveau
que ça arrive à 30 minutes voilà dix ans
que c'est une sécurité pour
l'organisation et pour les joueurs que
l'adversaire va jouer dans un temps
correct on va se rappeler des parties du
siècle dernier
oulaï avait pas de plus les voir durer
huit heures ça des parties pouvoir y
aurait deux jours plus réfléchir autant
qu'il voulait donc ça c'est très
important dans les échelles moderne
c'est au niveau de compétition cette
faculté donc que doivent avoir les
joueurs de gérer leurs temps de trouver
des solutions dans un temps limité
kasparov qui bouge les gens encore
énervé donc là ici bon bah oui c'est un
petit échange on va posséder un petit
échange
alors voilà je prend le micro bleus et
eluard hollande va me rejoindre
donc là kasparov en difficulté encore
une fois ça fait deux fois qui se fait
surprendre dans l'ouverture dimanche
pour la première partie avec les blancs
il n'a pas prévu l'ouverture qu'a choisi
chroniques et du coup il a dû perdre
beaucoup de temps pour trouver un plan
il s'en est bien sorti et et chronique a
sorti est sorti de cette partie avec le
point du match le demi point du match
nul en poche qui est toujours une bonne
affaire avec les noirs là par contre
kramnik a encore surpris kasparov d'un
l'ouverture semble-t-il et cas soit on
perd du temps ils dépensent énormément
d'énergie pour trouver le bon plan
la force de kasparov faut le rappeler
ces deux avant là il va jouer là à
l'appui on prend des quatre ça c'était
prévisible
c'était ce que nous avions prévu tout à
l'heure donc non là les blancs vont
répondre sans hésiter par pions prendre
des quatre grammy va jouer ça très vite
c'est évidemment le coup voilà il le
joue tout de suite puis on prend les
quatre donc la casse par on va sûrement
échanger les dames damas cinq prend dam
des deux il va sûrement jouer vite
puisque là il y avait une décision
stratégique à prendre mais une fois
qu'il l'a prise il a plus le choix il
peut pas reculer
donc là il faut allant et venant
surprise petite surprise il fait d'abord
fou prend des quatre ans c'était une
grande que je crois eloi et robert ont
analysé tout à l'heure donc c'est une
possibilité aussi puisque dans cette
position c'est tendu mais les noirs
tiennent tous ces dark si les blancs
prennent à damas 5
le cavalier c6 prend la dame le food et
4 et sans protection mais le cavalier
attaque le fouille à tours on va voir ça
avec le grand maître et loire relance tu
vas nous expliquer cette variante qui a
été envisagée par
robert fontaine tout à l'heure de retour
avec vous pour cette partie
exceptionnelle
donc ça y est ça ça a évolué les joueurs
ont joué donc là on va voir sur notre
échiquier de démonstration les coûts qui
viennent d'être joués donc garry
kasparov a pris en d4 fusion prend des
quatre est là et il faut prendre et 4
soup rang des cas donc c'était une
variante que vous aviez envisagé tout à
l'abri tout à fait tout ap donc nous
l'avions envisagé c'est même bon à mon
avis c'était le bon coup mais il nous
avions vu un problème avec robert
puisque dans cette position je crois que
les dons avait un coût assez for food et
5 peut-être
il s'agissait de foot des 5 fu des cinq
a l'air fort pourquoi alors on va
expliquer ça eh ouais tranquillement
food et 5 à la embêtant pourquoi alors
parce qu'on y travaille et c6 voit tout
de suite et attaquer il faut noter que
ce qu'alice ici se protègent deux points
essentiels de la position noir
c'est-à-dire le pion aux 7 et la dame à
5 et le four dégâts le fou des quatre il
protège tout en fait c'est un cavalier
clés comme on l'appelle qu'est-ce qui se
passe il a joué kramnik krainik il a
joué à aurait joué il a joué il a joué
il a joué alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joués
on ne voit pas encore alors là c'est
très surprenant
il semblerait que l'échiquier soit
bloqué l'échiquier les jt est bloqué à
il ya un problème il est un problème
alors là il faudrait faire un plan sur
l'échiquier
est ce qu'on peut faire un plan serré si
c'est possible sur l'échiquier pour
contre devine à peu près le coût de
kramnik est ce que c'est possible alors
je pense que ça va l'être oui ça va
l'être mais ça va prendre sûrement un
peu de temps alors là je suppose que
c'est la grosse panique c'est la beauté
et chic électronique à wisques
électronique semble-t-il à une
défaillance ça peut arriver alors on
peut pas nous ne distinguons pas grand
chose sur ce plan là c'est presque bon
il faudrait à voile alors alain nous
allons pouvoir d'écouté 5 fu des cinq
chroniques à jouer fou dessin au lycée
c'est le coup alors là on va voir
l'échiquier démonstration de tout de
suite c est très beau plat on va noter
le évidemment le temps on est à 1h31
ça c'est important parce que là pour la
première fois les chèques électroniques
a raté le pouvoir venir à ce plan
au niveau l'ariel voilà très beaux plans
on devrait obliger à ce moment-là de
deviner la position de loin parce que
les chèques électroniques à une
défaillance
voilà c'est martine prévu c'est superbe
frappe les que c'est une technologie qui
marche
d'habitude très très bien et équitable
on met deux cent vingt ans peut être
sujet à des petites défaillances suffit
qu'on marche mal sur un fil et puis et
puis voilà donc la dir hier il y avait
eu un petit problème la partie
recommence en retard pour une
explication très simple c'est que donc
vite fait petite parenthèse avant de
revenir sur la position c'est que le
câble qui arrivait pour alimenter dans
la loge 2k sports son échiquier à lui
montrant le prix sont réelles avait été
tout simplement sectionné donc quatre
portes n'avait plus la position et donc
il savait pas que cram qu'avait joué et
donc vous d'autres il y avait perdu du
temps il n'était pas content non c'était
avant que la partie commence avant alors
on va tout de suite voir l'échiquier de
démonstration parce que là on peut jouer
le coup voilà food et 5k jouer chronique
kasparov réfléchissez le coup qui tue
parce que là attention le cavalier sait
si cette attaque et il protège de cette
a5 et d4 et que peut faire kasparov si
boucher cavalier de lamm à 5 est perdu
la menace est donc faut prendre
cavaliers la menace peut être aussi ici
de faire d'emprunt dame cavaliers panda
mais fo prend fou qui a l'air de gagner
une pièce tout à fait
donc il faut que les noirs probablement
face dame à 5,30 dam des deux je vois
pas trop d'amertume ponam d2 c'est ce
que nous avions envisagé avec robert
salas d'être obligé sinon les noirs sont
dans la panade donc d'un pro d2 alors
voyons la variante ici c'est une
variante évidemment donc d'apprendre des
deux pour les noirs font prend des deux
il faut reprendre la dame évidemment et
le pub local c6 est toujours attaquer le
cas et c6 évidemment est attaqué c'est
un problème donc plusieurs possibilités
soit on le défend en mettant une tour
sur la classe très vite soit on déplace
le cavalier sur la case e 5
oui qui a l'air de menacer quelque chose
d'ailleurs le cas lors cavignaux 5 nous
l'avions regarder avec robert fontaine
donc sa menace le pion f3 c'est à dire
que si par exemple les blancs font tout
reprendre le 7
on va pas montré la variante mais on va
là signalé avec des cases les cavaliers
trois options f3 échec au roi qui
attaquent le fou des deux donc c'est ça
s'appelle les lois une attaque double
une fourchette même une fourchette ou
attaque douloureux événement fait la
même chose
fourchette étant le terme de
vulgarisation voilà l'état comme
fourchette aux échecs c'est donc une
double attaque comme ça c'est souvent le
cavalier qui fait la force alors nous
avons analysé cette position avec robert
fontaine et nous avions deux déduit
qu'elle était très compliqué mais
probablement al'avantage de vladimir
kramnik qui dispose de beaucoup de
possibilités ici il peut jouer par
exemple fois ci ce qui est un coup très
intéressant il peut jouer face à murray
que l'échiquier réel d'ailleurs soit
réparée il semblerait qu'ils ont réparé
puisque le fou des cinq a été jouée
alors la famille possible aussi qu' il
soit le coût était jouée manuellement
alors qu'à 1200 c'était la première
possibilité est ce que c'est bien est-ce
que c'est mal qu'est ce qu'il faut que
je voulais blanc peut-être roi g2 est
menacée f4 alors qu'est-ce qui ne font
que jouent les blancs c'est une faute et
stimuler que faut-il que les blancs jour
et dieu croit-il que les blancs jour et
c'était une question qui est bien un
bien meilleur on peut envisager ici fou
à justice par exemple qui est une contre
attaque le coup logique je pense est
quand même le coup droit chez 2000 plus
simple mais ici les noirs jouerait au
cices voilà c'est ce six chasseurs food
les cases des 5 et enlevant la taxe sur
la tour de la tour sur le pion et les
blancs ici devrait se borner à voir un
petit avantage mais néanmoins un
avantage durable
donc ça c'est une possibilité roger 2
c'est un coût possible après 4,5
on peut également envisager le coup food
et 2 h 6 pour gagner du temps mais là
probablement les noirs jouent tourbe 1,8
protégeant le pion aux sept
tranquillement tour en huit c'est
possible
né après f4 il y aura des choses une
chose est certaine dans cette position
les blancs l'initiative ils ont beaucoup
de possibilités on va donc revenir à la
variante à la position réelle à lord
précédente
d'ordinaire la position galerie fou des
5 ici nous allons enlever les flèches
pour bien comprendre les enjeux de cette
position le cahier des cinq qui est un
défenseur
très important de la position noir est
en train d'être attaquée
donc la première possibilité que nous
avions envisagé c'était de jouer en pro
d2 nous allons maintenant regarder
peut-être un autre coup on n'en voit pas
d'autres ordres à d'autres puisque
l'autre solution serait de mettre le fou
des quatre sur les casser alors est ce
que les blancs n'ont n'a pas vu la sauva
riante où les noirs je voudrais touré
fils évite par exemple à leurs tours fc
wiltz et non pas tout de suite mais
peut-être d'amsterdam et après alors
d'hommes programme c'est un autre coup
effectivement d'apprendre et de foot pro
d2 et maintenant défendre le cavalier
avec la tour f
la tour eiffe salaire salaire ça leur
logique parce que les blancs peuvent
prendre le cavalier c6 et après prend le
piano 7 mai ils ont donné la paire de
fou ils ont donné la peur de fouet après
tour ces deux les lans récupère le pion
les noires récupérées le pion puis ce
qu'ils attaqueraient le fou des deux est
le pion à 2 mais alors là ça devient
compliqué le fait est qu'il faut qu'on
sait si ce n'est pas un bon plan ou
leurs 43 pour cramique c'est à dire que
cradi câbles utilisés à peine 17 minutes
moins d'une minute par moins de une
minute par coup donc il est il est
forcément kramnik en terrain connu et
kasparov lui il lui reste 46 minutes il
a utilisé une heure et quart
ça veut dire qu'il ya un énorme décalage
de temps ça prouve que kramnik a surpris
kasparov d'un l'ouverture ça prouve donc
que kasparov et d'un terrain mal connu
en tout cas mal préparé et qu' il ya
encore en difficulté aujourd'hui comme
il avait pu l'être dimanche sur la
préparation de kramnik kasparov en
difficulté c'est clair il a une fois de
plus une heure de retard et il peut pas
s'exprimer kasparov et là il s'est
kramnik est en train de lui imposer son
rythme nouveau problème avec lâcheté
d'un guidage ou alors il faut absolument
faire un plan poussé trois fossés 3 c3
il a joué vous ces trois crânes et la
kasparov se lève
casper se lève il a l'air serein est
cette fois ci il a l'air d'avoir tout
calculer ces trois tranquillement
kasparov veut pas échanger les dames un
coup qu'on n'avait pas envisagé à
kasparov et hino remarque bien fait nos
marques à l'arbitré on a vu l'arbitré
est ce qu'on peut voir l' arbitre qui
est en train de vérifier ce qu'a dit
kasparov
elle aura alors peut-être que grâce à
notre réalisateur nous allons pouvoir
voir les images au ralenti de ce qui
s'est passé je ne sais pas en tout cas
si on les a ce sera tant mieux pour
mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
non je pense pas qu'on puisse le faire
on ne pourra peut-être pas le faire je
pense pas qu'on puisse le faire donc la
trame nick krainik est en réflexion
alors c'est un goût qu'on n'avait pas
prévu ça et loi alors il faut cette fois
j'étais en train d'en parler quand tu la
dérive est sûre je ne sais plus quel
sujet ah mais nous étions en train
d'aborder cette possibilité le fait est
que c'est un coût qui al'avantage de
garder les dames sur l'échiquier
voilà donc sa contre attaque la dame
blanche et du coup ça va permettre de
libérer qu'a laissé six hangars d'un les
dames sur l'échiquier
oui tout à fait donc bon le couple
logique qu'on a envie de jouer dans
cette position ces deux coups dame en e2
puisque le cavalier noir viendra
vraisemblablement sur la case aux cinq
ça ça paraît très probable
donc l'enjeu de cette position à mon
avis on va y revenir mais je prends ici
que kasparov a l'air bien décidé à jouer
finale de foot qu'on leur pose et c'est
à dire après dame de kent et 4 va
prendre en d4
non je pense que si on entame de calais
des quatre jours et d'inde d un oui
d'âme des uns c'est une autre
possibilité à l'air de garder la
pression et sa garde l'impression soit
cavaliers et après le coup cette hausse
il y aura des problèmes pointent les
blancs en prônant des 4 way mais ça fera
une finale égale sa frappe n'est
simplement ça fera peut-être une finale
non ici à priori
kasparov sera jamais une finale le foot
que l'on posé avec un temps moins ce
n'est pas une bonne chose
de toute façon kasparov est clairement
sur la défense alors je me dis qu'est ce
que ça veut dire une finale de fou de
couleurs opposées
ça veut dire que les fous ne seront pas
de la même couleur puisqu'ils seront de
couleur opposée
voilà donc où il y aurait un fou de
cases blanches du côté blanc un fou de
cases noires du côté noir et souvent ce
type de finale amène à la nulle parce
que on ne peut pas contrôler donc les
cases de la couleur opposée de son foule
on a du mal à pousser les pions oui
alors tout évidemment quand audi finale
de football a opposé ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya plus que des fous il ya plus de
cavaliers plus de tours et plus de dames
ou sinon on parle de finale football
imposé avec des pièces supplémentaires
mais quand il ne reste plus que les fous
en général on arrive à bloquer tous les
pions et demi sur la couleur de notre
propre fou alors leur problème c'est que
il reste et uri des dames ayant détourné
d'un donc là quand c'est pas une finale
le foot me reposer quand c'est une
position avec des fous de plus reposé et
des pièces lourdes là en général c'est
la tap qui prime c'est le joueur qui a
l'initiative qui peut attaquer qui a les
meilleures chances
un principe quand il ya des footballeurs
opposé le nombre de pions importe peu
évidemment toutes proportions gardées
donc là donc tu proposes le ku'damm
pourquoi dame de deux heures pour
protéger la case f3 pour protéger avec
les f3 fait on peut mettre la dame en d1
mais c'est pas une casse très très très
très intéressant à noter que ce soit
mais la dame en d3 lecavalier qui bondit
sur la case de cinq attaques la dame
donc ça gagne du temps ça a pas l'air
très bons donc reste dans me2 oh lord
and day 1 6 gramme il veut éviter les
changes de la peur de vous il joue
peut-être d'âme des uns ils menacent
peut-être devenir en b3 oui voilà encore
brillant quand même peut-être le coude à
ne pas ce qu'on ne sait toujours pas de
clown est en train de jouer dans cette
position que propose que proposait la
machine
la machine propose de défendre le
cavalier par tour à ses mythes non mais
elle est proposée la machine proposée le
sida mode on a lâché 2 proposait un coup
très très bizarre que je n'ose pas
mentionné puisqu'il était vraiment
affreux kelkoo le ku'damm cm1 case
totalement alternative et donc indigne
de pensionnés dans ses commentaires il
faut faire attention aux aspects
cycliques judiciaire on indique ne
mettra pas la dame en c1
c'est une question de principe un tour
assez min celle ci est une possibilité
ici donc là c'est pas laissez pas la
position réelle on vous rappelle c'est
une étude dans la position où sont les
joueurs voilà la position réelle
donc là on propose le coutour ac 8
protège en kabylie c6 ou alors
évidemment les blancs peuvent gagner un
pion en jouant four prend cavaliers tout
reprend quéré et tour prend peu fait ça
fait un campus mais le fait que le roi
non roi au blanc soit dans une position
très critiques puisqu'il ya plus de
pions devant lui est une compensation
largement suffisante pour les noirs qui
ici ne risquerai absolument rien donc a
priori sur le coup tours assez vite
alors là je me perds un trou ces deux
points m 2 tours assez vite on ne
jouerait pas fou prend 6,6 où il faut
rechercher une autre possibilité et je
ne sais pas vraiment laquelle
la position noir alerte nabeul puisque
évidemment à venir le coup au 7e 6 ce
qui nous amène donc à reconsidérer les
cases pour la dame au chapeau 6 avec
l'avantagé de chasser le fou des cinq
qui pour l'instant bien placé et pose
des problèmes au noir à cause du cabinet
sis en l'air à cause aussi du fait
qu'ils tapent sur le pion à vii et ça
peut avoir un rôle important important
alors peut-être qu'on peut voir les
images de chroniques la chronique va
peut-être utilisé son temps de réflexion
il est mal cadre il a alors là on peut
voir dans cette fois ci on a un plan
d'ensemble
si on pouvait voir un plan d'ensemble
général voilà voilà donc la chronique
tout seul et la chaise de kasparov
évident
et si à lui de réfléchir à l'enfant
rappelé donc qu'il a utilisée à peine 23
minutes de son temps pour les 16
premiers coups alors que kasparov a
utilisé une heure et quart et qui lui
reste donc que 45 minutes pour atteindre
le 40e coup
fossé 3-1 chronique n'avait pas prévu ce
couple semblablement oui on le voit sa
tête la wii mais il a pas l'air il n'a
pas prévu mais il n'a pas l'air non plus
très embarrassé hawaï c'est amusant
parce qu'avoir des calculs sur les
variantes
c'est sûr mais il regarde pas les chics
et il regarde par l'échiquier
tout se passe dans la tête
très serein vladimir eric qui ferment et
dieu est ce qu'on pourrait pas le cadre
et sur ce plan le plan précédent un peu
plus adroite puisqu'il n'est pas au
centre de l'épreuve sont là combien je
pense qu'on peut le faire
et d'ailleurs on va probablement le
faire alors est ce qu'on peut voir la
marque des lunettes de vladimir kramnik
peut-être les femmes et non je n'arrive
pas je n'arrive pas à voir la marque de
céline est nommé peu importe ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que bon petit rappel
pour ceux qui arrivent en cours de route
ces deux matches garry kasparov qu'on ne
l'a dit mercredi que le numéro 1 contre
le numéro deux mondial
c'est au riverside studio à londres donc
dans un studio de télé comme vous voyez
le décor juste derrière qui montre bien
qu'on sait faire et c'est un match de
championnat du monde jouée pour la
société brenda et voilà il retransmis
donc sur internet en exclusivité par
canal web en partenariat vivendi games
sur le site de canal web et le site de
braine games ainsi que sur le site de
libération le journal francilien connu
et le site de la fédération française
des échecs partenaire de l'émission
diagonale qui retransmet cet événement
c'est vraiment le grand événement de
l'année échiquéen puisque ça faisait
cinq ans que kasparov n'avait pas joué
un match pour le titre de meilleur
joueur du monde
alors on parle plus de deux champions du
monde officiel puisque la fédération
internationale des échecs organise son
propre championnat championnat du monde
le champion du monde de la fédération
c'est alexander kalichman mais il est
30e joueur mondial il n'a pas démontré
dans l'année
qui valait le titre de meilleur joueur
du monde puisqu'il n'a pas gagné
beaucoup de partis s'est même fait
battre de linares disons que pour faire
un petit point sur le paysage des
champions du monde du monde donc de la
planète terre il ya quatre joueurs qui
peuvent prétendre actuellement être
champion du monde
on sait mais tout le monde sait bien que
c'est kasparov le meilleur joueur ces
quatre joueurs c'est évidemment donc
alexander zalivin le champion du monde
le filet est également un atelier karpov
qui est en procès contre la fidh et qui
est en procès contre le filet pour
récupérer son titre de champion du monde
et il ya aussi robert fischer dit bobby
qui qui lui n'a jamais été battu dans un
match de championnat et qui seraient
revenus aux états unis donc voilà devant
les très belles images générées par
notre réalisateur
yannick voit la chronique qui réfléchit
un petit point position qu'au théâtre
ouais on va revenir sur notre échiquier
voilà réflexion toujours de travnik
après ce coup fous ces trois joué par
gary kasparov fou qui vient donc
attaquer la dame en d2 vous avez sans
doute cette position sur votre applet
java à droite de l'échiquier le fou ces
trois attaques la dame d2 pas sûr pas
sûr dit stéphane aborde qui s'est occupé
personnellement que l'applet marche
voilà donc il est donc bien placé pour
vous dire que ce n'est pas sûr reprenons
alors peut-être avec cette position
stéphane une toile avec les blancs si tu
avais les pièces blanches dans cette
position de contre garry kasparov que je
vois tu es bien
non mesdames 2 à l'air le coup le plus
logique ou donne d un oui dames c'est un
vrai que dame c'est un pas l'air on va
pas trop l'idée de dames c est en fait
on voit pas trop l'idée de dames c'est
un oui c'est vrai peut-être attaque
elles font ces trois noms je ne sais pas
bon alors on va peut-être regarder une
finale typique dans cette position qui
pourrait arriver par exemple mettons que
les banques jouent une dame ces deux là
une possibilité d'accès 2 ici nous
envisageons qu'elle a aidé quatre fous
prend cavaliers food rend fou et tour
trempions le set
cette finale évidemment les joueurs sont
en train d'y penser
oui ont déjà pensé en tout cas il faut
l'évaluer dans un premier temps bon
la première chose à dire c'est que les
blancs entre un club plus et ce monde
sont probablement mieux de en fait en
plus qu'ils attaquent le pion à vii et
avec le fouet avec la tour un poids
important
maintenant la question c'est est ce que
les noirs ne peuvent pas commencer à
attaquer le roi blanc également par
exemple un choix un coup comme dante
vite on peut proposer ici oui essayer de
passer la dame vers le roi d'un des 800
dans cette optique assez intéressante à
lui nommé la tour la torah 8 étant
prises également
et oui il a tort invite par le fou non
donc ici à priori oui alors peut-être
tour assez vite d'abord c'est très
important d'évaluer bien cette position
puisque elle arrive dans énormément de
variantes beaucoup de transpositions
beaucoup de dents de droit c'est vite
dit la dame b3 qui augmente la pression
sur f7 thème mettra augmente la pression
sur kiev 7 un psycho la menace est
carrément tout reprend pion à vii ou
éventuellement même [ __ ] en pillant et
vii avec échecs et les noirs sont dans
la panade dans la panade mais ce n'est
pas forcément grave puisque ici il y à
tour ces trois mettons ces trois ont
fait feu prend f7 faut prendre cet échec
échec lors un noir vient se cacher sur
la case à chocs 8 par exemple voilà et
là peut-être le coup par exemple dame d
un homme d un pas mal mais permettrait
quand même
au noir de gagner la tour sete part
d'alger cinq échecs et voilà le piège le
piège donc ici maintenant il faut
montrer quand même nous avons été un
petit vittek mais avec le roi et en même
temps gagne la tour c'est depuis ce que
laurent blanc doit bouger
donc il faut faire attention mesdames d1
est pas possible alors peut-être l'ombre
et alors la position après le premier
set et rouages suite est très très tendu
dans la mesure où les noirs ont planifié
de jouer d'amd sein d'amgen 5 et cher il
faut jouer peut-être dame au 6 9 6 mais
l'option f3 est en prise et ici je pense
que laurent blanc serait plus faible que
le roi noir donc contre chance pour les
noirs ici et c'est difficile à évaluer
difficile à évaluer revenons dans cette
position
notre finale que nous cherchons à
évaluer tout reprendre 7 est ici tour
assez vite avec une position vraiment
pas clair probablement meilleur pour les
blancs comme ça c'est une chose
chronique évidemment la vue donc si on
revient la vraie position la position
réelle et noir viennent de jeu le fou
ces trois attaques la dame de garry
kasparov et c'est très chaud et la crds
amigo il dit c'est pour ça qu'il prend
son temps de réflexion
il est vraiment à fond là on le voit il
est à fond notre vladimir puisque c'est
le moment crucial pour lui il faut qu'il
se décide pour un plan faut qu'il se
décide pour les différentes possibilités
fonds qui m la dame sur une case naturel
la case naturel pour la dame
à mon avis c'est la case eux deux mais
ce n'est pas sûr puisque on va peut-être
sur dame 2 si on joue silenor joue car
ils étaient quatre puisque le câble est
attaqué il faut rappeler qu'il faut
bouger ce cavalier dame de chaldée
quatre dames des seins à l'air embêtant
puisque on en avait déjà parlé stéphane
mais c'était effectivement pas claires
pas clair du tout mais je crois qu'il y
avait le coup eux c'est aussi ce qui
donner une solution au problème des
noirs mais je sais pas moi ça me plaît
bien se comprendre un des quatre avec le
fou ouais mais c'était la finale des
expériences signifie n'allait nulle
comprend mieux la prime meilleurs avions
passé pour les blancs aux cintres quand
même un pion passé au centre bon et le
roi blanc est trop faible à mon avis
dans cette finale c'est une finale deux
tours pour lui faire une finale ça peu
de l'ain et on ne peut pas changer d'un
malheureusement ces dames prennent des
cinq classes et fictifs alors quel écran
nous avons craint ni qui réfléchit donc
effectivement on va pas trop s'attarder
sur des variantes de ce style alors on
va voir on va voir ce que ce soit juste
crânien en tout cas il a l'air la g5
rami que si on le regarde bien eloi
regarde il a pas l'air embêté il alors
de calculer des variantes
on le sent confiant le fait et qui a
évidemment chronique dans cette question
ne risque rien les blancs sont mieux
c'est sûr donc chronique est tout à fait
serein tout à fait tranquille
là il faut rappeler la différence d'âge
si un crâne et donc à 24 ou 25 ans à 25
ans il va voir et kasparov 37
oui ce qui peut jouer un rôle dans ce
match cela dit c'est un marché de court
c'est un match en sept parties c'est
vrai donc ça permettra probablement et
garry kasparov de ne pas s'essouffler
mais le rythme est fort aussi des
parties ces seize parties mais aussi
qu'avant quand il faisait 2 machelon y
avait possibilité pour joueurs de
prendre un jour de repos ce genre de
choses là c'est pas possible il ya quand
même quatre parties par semaine c'est un
rythme assez élevé il n'y a pas
si donc le mardi le jeudi le samedi et
le dimanche donc là deux parties
d'affilée
c'est quand même un ring il faut
soutenir faut rappeler que les jours de
repos bon mais faut que les joueurs se
préparent donc qu'ils n'ont pas c'est
pas vraiment du repos donc un moment
donné la résistance physique peut jouer
un rôle
je vais donc l'âge aussi peut jouer un
rôle kasparov ont mécaniquement fait
très sportif c'est vrai que c'est vrai
kasparov et très sportif et que et qu'a
priori ils ne risquent pas grand chose
au niveau de la résistance physique
alors des nouvelles venues de
l'extérieur
il s'agit de robert fontaine qui va
revenir faire un petit tour aux
commentaires j'avais lui passer la
parole
voilà robert donc tu vas commenter
quelques coups avec stéphane laborde
voilà je te passe le micro voilà donc
robert fontaine nous rejoint pour
combien de temps je sais pas encore qui
est alors encore pour on ne sait pas
combien de temps région et qui nous
rejoint on rappelle que robert fontaine
fait partie des espoirs français
caricaturaux bien exactement bientôt
haye en novembre
donc la position évoluer
alors fou c3 c'est la première fois que
chronique et réfléchi longtemps
et oui alors plusieurs casses pour la
dame peut-être de ces deux je ne sais
pas ce que vous en avez ce que vous avez
dit sur ce coup là me 2 à l'air naturel
donc moi je me poserai la question de
cavaliers des quatre cavaliers b4 donc
un petit problème technique
bon stéphane donc cramique réfléchir
c'est la première fois le problème est
réglé d'ennuis avec mon micro alors j'ai
vu kasparov réclamer quelque chose à
l'arbitré il n'avait pas l'air très
content oui c'est vrai je sais pas ce
qu'il s qui lui a demandé mais alors
d'un e 2
alors est-ce que vous avez analysé
cavalli b4 non moi je moi je pensais à
ce coup cavaliers mais quatre pour faire
pour 1 bat attaqué directement le fond
en d5 à wissant dames 2 oui dames 2
cavaliers v4 le fou blanc doit partir
apparemment ou alors en paix c'est une
combinaison partout reprend cavaliers b4
dame prend b4 par exemple est fou prend
la torah 8 mai cet échange je pense nous
donne pas grand chose aux blancs alors
on va regarder cette variante
tranquillement donc ici une possibilité
pour kramnik
dans me2 donc c'est de jouer le contre
dans man 2 et la proposition de robert
fontaine cavaliers des 4 est ce que les
blancs ne pourrait pas jouer de tout
reprendre cavaliers oui ce que j'ai
mentionné mais je ne sais pas à quoi ça
sert par exemple pour prendre b4 d'un
prendre b4
c'est joli mais pour l'heure si les
blancs jouent pour prendre les quatre
dames où je prends je vais en prendre
quatre des cinq peut récupérer la
portant à 1 min mais après tout rend fou
et les blancs donné leur part de fou
tout à fait et peut-être les noirs sont
maintenant légèrement lui-même et
peut-être les noirs sont légèrement
mieux une cavale et bk tenté de donner
la paire de fou simple pour par un père
de fouace et c'est un motif surtout dans
cette position c'est le seul à thoune et
blanc donc là c'est difficile de
proposer un coup dans cette position
dams et 2 mc2a l'inconvénient de laisser
la dame sur la colline verte surtout
après deux tours c'est 8 où on peut
envisager tour assez vite par exemple
avec des découvertes éventuel quand le
fond bougera donc c'est la première fois
que krainik réfléchi et il a l'air
embêté relativement ouais je pense que
là il va utiliser son temps de réflexion
c'est un coup qu'il avait sûrement pas
prévu
or c'est aussi un motif de
de choix dans une partie de jouer un
coup pas forcément le meilleur mais le
coût qui est le moins attendu par la
terre c'est oui possible c'est
possiblement en plus c'est à dire d'être
fort qu ici on aime de a l'air vraiment
naturellement je sais pas ce que tu que
ton lundi avec éloi voyait d'amener leur
naturel et doit proposer sur d'un mode
de cavaliers des 4 et après la prise par
exemple mais après moi je sais pas je
pensais prison d'âme des uns qui se met
à perdre est encore un temps sa part des
peut-être un temps donc d'un me deux
cavaliers des 4 et la question c'est est
ce que les blancs prennent cavaliers ou
est-ce qu'on joue dame sur la case d1
alors et loi propose faut prendre
cavaliers et après fou prend fou tour
par 7 à rigoler petit avantage blanc oui
tout à fait
un bon avantage puisque c'est quand même
un pion plus c'est un point de plus
belle et plus encore les biens les
langues les pions de doubler oui c'est
des fous de couleur reposer donc ça
favorise a priori il attaque et le pion
à vii et est relativement faible surtout
auprès des dames c4 la menace est quand
même c'était direct donc ici c'est un
bon avantage un bon avantage blanc et je
pense pas kasparov rentrera dans cette
variante salaires datant de moins d'un
intervenant à une pression sur l'a47
effectivement un alain gourg ici
attaquerez le pion à 7 et des du fou des
5 suivi par james et kat ce qui ferait
une triple attaque en plus la tour et
attaquer la torah plus il faut il faut
jouer cette tour et voilà c'est
quasiment difficile casino veut tuer
ouais parce que la menace d'armes c4
attaquerez le coût des quatre
expositions très difficile non je pense
plutôt que voilà plus de cavaliers des
quatre il peut y avoir un autre coup par
exemple tour à ses 8
c'est effectivement une possibilité tour
assez vite car la source de la tacc du
fouet donné le pion aux 7
ça donne aux clients un set contre l'amf
est de récupérer un fou menace aussi ce
donc fou prend à l'air force et je
prends cavaillé photo en clavier pour
prendre pour un set pour prendre un set
avec comme ça en plus mes mails à 10 ans
les noirs sont sait mieux que tout à
l'heure
tout à l'heure à les noirs et par
exemple jouer je sais pas d'un match 5
pour menacer fouet 5 et essayer de
monter une attaque contre le roi blanc
mais au nom mais je pense le cavaly bk
très intéressant et je vois pas de coups
de coups concret contre contre cavaliers
v4 dame de deux cavaliers b4 cramique
clichés toujours
alors dame de cavalli bekaert four b3
par exemple pour retirer à la place de
tout reprend cavaliers comme tu comme tu
l'a indiqué tout à l'heure le four b3 et
maintenant beaucoup comme tomber 8
donc la cram mis tout seul en courant
affectant alors là il va sûrement
utiliser la musique sociale ce qui ira
jusqu'à présent on a surtout vu un gary
kasparov alors on va rappeler que si les
joueurs réfléchissent moment donné assez
longtemps comme c'est le cas à les
positions c'est autant de temps perdu
pour la suite
donc c'est pas réfléchir autant de temps
comme ça sur chaque coup et ont aussi
réfléchi c'est qu'ils sentent que c'est
un des tournants de la partie donc c'est
très important
voilà donc là après une fois que crâne
foire réfléchir on aura sûrement droit à
une rafale de coups donc on va revenir à
la position initiale
on est où là je ne sais plus j'ai bien
appris
1h18 contre 45 minutes donc tout à
l'heure on était proches de leur est
maintenant s'approche petit à petit
vers le quart d'heure
les cinq pouces et 3 est la question
alors peut-être un coup comme démonter
un bon plan sur crâne boucle en
appréciant voix marmonne un petit peu
avec les lèvres c'est un petit peu
décousu et pas mal de joueurs font ça
comme karpov par exemple qu'il le fait
quasiment tout le temps way we se répète
ses variantes
c'est une manille après jour du pain ils
se renvoient l'échiquier d'hommes
perspectives dans la river
or kremnica vais tous vous débitez tous
débuté quasiment tempo tous ces coups
maintenant réfléchi peut-être qu'ils
n'avaient pas prévu dans sa préparation
fossé 3 c'est possible ouais c'est parce
qu'ils aient pas prévu en tout cas
kasparov sa dépense énormément de temps
pour le trouver oui peut-être qu'il
avait nous peut-être il avait estimé que
ce coût était pas bon il est en train de
se rappeler pour quelles raisons moi et
mes malheurs bon 1h15 ce coût à la forme
et moi je pense que le problème sur des
menaces et qu'elle valait b4 des
cavaliers des quatre cavaliers b4 et
l'ordre d'hama 2 on va voir
donc le problème c'est d'être cavaliers
des quatre salles à un peu un peu risqué
de mettre tout un peu les pièces comme
ça en l'air le fou c3 n'est plus protégé
mais ça délais ont posé une question au
fond en blanc un dessin qui est très
très fort donc il faut absolument
cavaliers à table déloger way et
peut-être après et noir jouent eux 7 6
par exemple par exemple pour par exemple
j'aime leur droit fou b3 on peut comme
comme je l'aï dit jouer par exemple d'un
match 5 aussi pourquoi pas d'armes h 5 h
5 pour poser une question déjà aux
blancs questions concrètes aux menaces
faut cinq dames h5
l'esa en l'occurrence est en prison oui
puisque surtout point cette fosse 5 de
gagner une qualité un fou aux cinq ici
attaque sans comprendre cette fois eu
cinq attaques le pion h2 avec la dame
est belle et noirs les blancs par
exemple ne peuvent pas jouer le coup f2
f3 puisque la dame eu deux surprises par
la dame h5 donc difficile à parer d'un
prof de maths il faut donner la tour
contre le fou et ça serait un petit
avantage noir donc ça peut basculer d'un
moment il faut faire très attention aux
cavaliers des 4 as l'air d'être un coût
qui va libérer la dame à 5 finalement
qui va permettre à la dame assez mal de
changer de côté ou alors faut que les
blancs donnent le fou et ça limite leur
avantage
non ici et blanc donne le fou je pense
qu'ils n'ont plus aucun avantage bien
même plus aucun avantage
par exemple pour prince est vraiment
mauvais cause de cavalli prend tout
d'abord comprendre qu'on peut faire
kramnik pour éviter éventuellement cette
variante parce qu'il en est un autre
choix peut-être amis que jouer d'âme des
uns oui mais voilà ça va pas ça a pas
l'air sa part et donc sur coup comme
dame c'est un rêve alors justement la
machine proposée doit vous le disais que
c'était un coup qu'avec qui était pas
bon mais la machine propose dames c'est
un s'appelle un très logique de mettre
la dame sur cette connerie j'ai un genou
après tour à ses 8 par exemple du coup
ça empêche cavaliers b4 c'est peut-être
pour ça oui
ce coup on paie ce qui arrive et 4
puisque sur cavalli b4 des noirs
évidemment la dame anciens ici à tacle
pouces et 3 qui est en prise donc c'est
pas possible
donc il faut là que les noirs je trouve
un autre coup et la menace des blancs
est toujours de prendre le cavaly c6
pour l'instant un retour à ses 8 par
exemple
alors maintenant le nord pourrait jouer
effectivement tour assez vite on
s'aperçoit que sur foot français six
tours qu'on sait si ce soir vous prend
tout reprend les noirs n'ont pas
vraiment de découverte désagréable
puisque la taureau c6 est pour l'instant
en l'air quoi alors une découverte
cedars-sinaï où il faut bougez bougez
par exemple sur la case de 5
si le fou donc va sur la case de cinq
ici la tour c 6 serait emprise de la
dame voilà la découverte c'est donc
découvrir la taille d'une pièce si le
football la tour attaque la dame mais
comme cette tournée pas défendu c'est
pas une découverte dangereuse
l'idéal en général pour faire ce genre
de choses c'est que le fou données
chèque
oui c'est parfait l'échec évidemment
faux parionsweb et après il faut prendre
la dame avec la tour tout simplement
donc la torah c'est 8
c'est possible ça a l'air de ça leur
bien pour les noires s'activent les
pièces il faut prendre aux cavaliers
tout reprend et
cavaliers tout reprendre et là je veux
pas trop de problèmes peut-être et
surtout reprendre confiance est hélas
faudrait que les blancs effectivement
face tout reprend pion aux 7 15e pions
et on l'a découvert on s'aperçoit
maintenant que la découverte par exemple
souhaité six attaques la tour ne sert à
rien voilà fois-ci s'il attaque à la
fois ici la tour 7 et la dame c'est un
parle avec 4,6 mais c'est pas grave il
suffit que les blancs prennent part dont
j'ai fait que les blancs prennent à la
tour c 6 elle se retrouve avec un pilon
et a prévu un plan nagua internet de
plus en plus les séries finales avec les
fous de même couleur
ça semble avantageux pour les blancs oui
là c'est vraiment gros avantage non donc
voilà une variante qui al'air d'avantagé
les blancs dont peut-être cramique
réfléchi adams et un de cookies pour
l'instant nous avait échappé toujours la
dame en tout cas c'est sûr ça va être un
cooldown 510 ch chronique dans le délire
il à la meuse d'un des détroits wayne
dam des trois par exemple permet
cavaliers 5 avec un iguane tempo donc je
pense pas que ce soit un candidat un
réseau on a vu dans le 2 ça n'a pas
l'air super non plus à cause des cas on
m'aide à me dehouck dames c'est un son
mono voulaient plus poser plausible
comme ces deux derniers deux hommes
c'est peut être bien aussi à cause de
tours fc a ensuite qu'il faudrait une
pression ouais ouais aussi ponctuel sur
le fou même c'est de le dire un 3/4 pour
la dame donc ça sera un de ces coups là
de son qui va être jouée par kramix est
sûre il est en train de réfléchir
simplement lequel est le meilleur
par exemple dams et 2
et là j'aime pas trop le ku'damm ces
deux parce que ils cassent war of pourra
jouer qu'à valider 4 par exemple et la
dame la dame en c2 ne contrôle plus ne
contrôle pas la case g5 donc après les
changes de foot case noire les noirs
pourront amener la dame au g5 par
exemple qu'à valider quatre ici donc par
exemple à l'aide des quatre pour les
noirs fou prend sous prend donc vous
prend vous prend et on s'aperçoit que la
case et 5 n'est pas défendu et après
aussi ce par exemple assez haut blanc de
jouer là mais tourcoing set pour prendre
un set pour les blancs
la nature en gagne un pion en effet donc
il faut peut-être pour mc2 est aussi
possible
là les blancs sont encore nettement
mieux dans la même position de thaler
sauf que la dame est en ce2 au lieu de
une possibilité que sinon les lois 7 m
dames des mythes wheels md huit dames
c'est cette voie là il concerne
l'effectif madame d'éviter là parce que
là si la tour bouge évidemment il ya un
échec ici peut être embêtant g5 ou en
tout cas la donne peut venir h4 avec une
pression sur leurs hôtes blanc mais il
suffit que l'anjou dame c7 et
l'échangent des dames et forcé avec une
finale avantageuse à jouer oui je sais
pas si c'est gagnant mais bon avantage
bon avantage armée - donc position
encore c'est à dire que la casse par ans
nous a pas gâtés avec une brune fait le
signe il est ancré et variantes un petit
peu aride
oui mais est-ce qu'il a le choix parce
qu'il paraîtrait que d'après la loi
maintenant la liste indienne n'est plus
trop à l'ordre du jour mais ils la
jouent ils la jouent donc on peut lui
faire confiance je pense
je sais pas
voilà belloy justement vous en dire plus
alors crème ni toujours plus d'inflexion
c'est émanant y la plus grande peine 25
minutes ce qui n'est pas énorme par
rapport à tout à l'heure
donc voilà je ne vous cache pas que nous
sommes dans une petite salle pour faire
des commentaires
effectivement on a du mal à s'organiser
pour ne pas faire de son blizzard
régulièrement
alors donc robert où en sommes-nous en
fait en résumant la situation de ce
match en fin de cette partie en tout cas
en quelques mots si c'est possible et
bien krainik a perdu un peu de son
avance au temps premièrement ce qui est
quand même tout à l'heure il avait
quasiment une heure maintenant il a un
peu moins de 25 minutes écrit kasparov
apparemment à trouver un bon coup on se
croyait que les blancs avaient un petit
avantage pour rien mais c'est pas si
claire croyable castrophe aurait trouvé
un bon goût voilà est sorti krainik de
sa préparation d'accords et mais gary
nous surprendra tout le temps puisqu'il
est capable de jouer des coups très fort
il faut ces trois donc la sorte aurait
sorti 15 lignes de sa préparation le
coup effectivement si on revient un
qu'auparavant c'est à dire voyant le
plaisir telle qu'elle était au coude
avant c'est à dire après le 16e coup de
crâne likoud s imbriquent lecouffe ou c3
est un peu moins il est porté en verre
mais sinon il était inattendue on
s'attendait plutôt à ce que les noirs
aille en finale
ouais et en fait non puisque gary
kasparov avec sa subtile compréhension
du jeu préféré regarder et dames sachant
que le roi de vladimir kramnik et les
fèves donc c'est logique double couche
et 3 très logique
alors là ya plusieurs cas sur la dame
c'est peut-être le moment de faire des
petits paris robert combien dias
possible déjà un an disait avec moi j'en
ai vu cinq temps à vue cinq d'accord
j'en ai vu cinq dont la case d3 qu'on va
éliminer a priori puisque elle a l'air
mauvaise elle permettrait aux cavaliers
c6 devenir en cinq avec un gain de temps
et donc de chasser la dame donc reste
quatre cases
alors là vraiment quatre cases et
chacune a l'air chaque case à son
avantage
chaque classe a des avantages et la case
ces deux donc on va détailler des
avantages de chacune des caves
oui 4 7 2 qui permet travail qu'on a la
dame date a lancé d'attaqué est toujours
le fou en c3 voilà qui empêche cavaliers
b4 et qui menacent torcéen qui lui tient
à déclarer qu'ils préparent tour c'est
un tout coup très logique donc dame ces
deux c'est un coup revoyons maintenant
une autre case la case c1
cette case là donc et les avantages de
cette crise la fillette
c'est quand même un coût qui est
difficilement accessible oui tout à fait
bon alors toujours la même idée de
d'avoir une pression sur un cas ces
trois éventuellement de conserver un
oeil sur la case g5 pour empêcher un
éventuel d'alger cinq échecs mais bon
pour l'instant on voit pas vraiment
comment un commun les noirs pour est
d'accord ça c'est vrai que la casse
justin qui est très important puisqu'on
voit régulièrement des attaques de maths
avec la dame noire qui venant d'ici ce
transfert sco angers 5 soit 11,5 et avec
des balles perspectives d' attaques
contre le roi blanc donc dame c1 serait
un coup en fait qui attaque et qui
défont à la fois voilà une sorte de coup
porté
revenons alors attention interventions
ici express
dans la cabine de commentaire
l'espérance a aurait appelé l' arbitre
dans sa loge et nous voyons leur sort ce
très beau plan générés par yannick à la
réal notre réalisateur
larbitre larbitre l'arbite que l'on voit
à droite de l'écran
effectivement un tout à l'heure kasparov
a appelé les arbitres sur la scène et
lui a fait signe avec la main avec deux
doigts alors je sais pas du tout ce que
ça veut dire les riquet vous dire ces
deux doigts c'est ça fait deux fois que
je sais vraiment a alors une information
peut-être arrive encore puisque nous
avons notre envoyé spécial stéphane
laborde qui va prendre des nouvelles
régulièrement alors stéphane kasparov a
l'air content donc il faut noter il faut
noter qu'il a l'air mécontent
voilà je le note nous sert vitre
peut-être que l'arbitré a tant que cram
nique et jeux à son cou pour un plan sur
un arbitre larbitre noir tel un vampire
d'un litre redouté par les joueurs dans
une sorte de nosferatu de cerises
versailles studio et elle a en
transforme en vampire quand il est à la
lumière et donc il n'y est jamais voilà
larbitre qu'on a vu sur ce plan alors il
nous reste deux cases
quand la dame nous reste donc de castres
26 notre real
yannick peut revenir à la position voilà
c'est fait donc ici nous avons regardé
déjà plusieurs cases
nous sommes en train de les détailler
après tout ces trois joué par gary
kasparov la position dans les caves du
manoir clichy nous avons éliminé je
prends les cas ces deux essais 1 pour
faire nous avons déjà indiqué qu'elle
gérait les avantages l'avantagé
principal de ces deux cases et de garder
le contrôle sur le foot est roi
pour éviter le coup cavale et ses 6 ans
b 4 entre autres entre toi alors autres
casses toi site d'amd un garden d un bon
pour moi c'est je comprends pas trop ce
coup oui ce coup semble ridicule c'est
peut-être ce qui va être jouée neige
à première vue d'amener un vraiment
n'est pas logique du tout on pas logique
du tout est ce que l'idée pourrait être
de jouer par exemple avec 4,4 après
contrôle et donc les cases du cahier c6
je pense que laurent blanc est elle
aussi déjà affaibli mais après 4 je sais
pas peut-être l'idée pourrait de jouer
des f4 la dame donc se révèle donc
restons là bien placé sur la case d1
mais essayer d'attaquer loin d'annoncer
un bien placé c'est relatif parce que
après tour des huit les blancs ont déjà
un problème
d'accord tout à fait donc d'âme des uns
va être éliminé dame d'hier n'est pas le
bon coup et ne sera pas jouée par
vladimir kramnik nous rions cette case
dams m2 alors à première vue le plus
logique puisque ça défend directement le
pion f3 est bon ça dépend directement de
leur histoire effectivement la lame est
assez bien cette année à saulieu
ça permet à la tour de sortir sur les
cas c'est un par exemple ou sur les
cases b1 ou sur les gaz d un
ça permet donc un développement naturel
des pièces donc maintenant nous
rappelons les enjeux de cette analyse
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
position garry kasparov bien que le foot
est roi il a sorti bladinières chronique
de sa préparation
krasniqi en train de réfléchir depuis un
bout de temps depuis déjà 48 45 minutes
quarante minutes et chronique à des
cases pour saddam nous avons éliminé pas
mal de gaz et nous sommes en train de
nous demander sur laquelle de ces trois
cases verte
il va aller avec sa dame est en tout cas
famille qui très très concentré pour
choisir la case où le mettra sa dame moi
je pense que dams et d'eux mêmes ces dom
par m me paraît meilleur et bien moi je
sais pas c'est intéressant ça pourrait
faire l'objet de certains appareils de
certains parient que va jouer
il admire carbonique dans cette position
alors attention parce que là si on peut
avoir un gros plan de crem nique géant
on a l'impression qu'il est très proche
de jouer son coup là voilà là vous avez
la pose du jour les chats qui va jouer
ça se sent il a lésés pour le bien
avancé
son bras droit est prêt à bondir pour
saisir la pièce est jouée son coup
rapidement il va filer dernière variante
gens là il est dans les dernières
vérifications krainik va bientôt jouer
et là larbitre en profitera pour sauter
les spectres ethnique et me faire des
romains de garry kasparov
que peut bien vouloir garry kasparov
on sait qu'il n'est pas content on ne
sait pas pourquoi mais en tout cas
krainik va se faire selon ces parle
arbitres non
on est reparti en arrière mais il a
l'air prêt à jouer mais kasparov
peut-être montre des signes de nervosité
s'il indique l arbitre un protestation
quelconque ça veut dire qu'il n'est pas
oui kasparov et nerveux et nerveux nous
sommes ici donc à londres en 2000 il ya
kasparov premier son titre en jeu ça
fait cinq ans qu'il ne l'a pas fait
c'est la deuxième partie il n'a pas
réussi à passer dans la première avec
les pièces blanches
là ils souffrent avec et noir et se
plaint à l'arbitré alors que le tram
nick a l'air tout à fait détendue dans
son fauteuil en cuir fauteuil en cuir
donc des années sur mesure puisqu'il est
très grand il mesure presque deux mètres
c'est très chaud mais c'est très très
chaud la dîmière crown et qui est très
avancé sur sanchez 3 cases pour saddam
fort at il de bons choix et une est en
droit de l'attendre
maintenant qu'elle est bon choix on ne
sait pas encore qu'est ce que tu penses
un avis personnel j'ai encore mettre la
position je vais vous donner mon avis
personnel mais là ça demande un petit
peu de concentration quand même puisque
c'est pas facile
moi je pense qu'il va mettre la dame sur
une case blanche
we7 lagacé de ueno mais maintenant la
pierre dhénin choix difficiles et à mon
avis dame ces deux modes de calcul akale
beaucoup de calculs ce qui doit
calculator c8 et envisager des
découvertes
alors est ce qu'on peut se mettre sur
l'échiquier de démonstration voilà c'est
vrai que le ku'damm ces deux donc a
priori la case normal la case la plus
logique celle que par exemple on est en
train de jouer le parti blitz on arrive
à cette position on a cinq minutes il
faut jouer un coup très vite tout est
bien tout le monde ira sur la case eux
deux pourquoi et bien simplement parce
que ya pas de tours qui peut être
peuvent attaquer la dame
ça permet à la tour et fin de passer non
car on va vite voir ce cookie et le coup
naturel et ça protège voilà le plus mais
franck protège le pion à f3 qui est
rouge ça permet la tour de sortir après
c'est le coup naturel sans aucun doute
maintenant effectivement la longue
réflexion de la lumière cramique laisse
présager le fait qu'il puisse celle sur
laquelle ces deux qui n'est pas naturel
puisque ici on peut envisager le coût
par exemple tour à 8 ans et vite
tout va vite on s'est vite qui chauffe
qui chauffe qui chauffe aime beaucoup
robert way avec une attaque indirecte
sur la dame dont on peut imaginer des je
sais pas c'est le problème c'est que bon
ça chauffe mais on voit pas directement
la menace noir c'est donc avec
directement cavaliers au 5 mai bon
niveau de 5
c'est une menace
c'est une menace peut-être le coup et
7,6 tout simplement oui positionnement
peut penser qu'ici les noirs voudrait
jouer de cet os 6 à mon avis voilà alors
si on revient à la position dans
laquelle fabrique réfléchi il est en
train de se demander comment faire pour
éviter que kasparov ne puisse jouer deux
sets 6 2 7 6 et son coût de pions
soucoupe pion qui est probablement la
clé de l'énigme
c'est dire si cramique arrive à le
prendre avec sa tour il aura une très
très bonne porte position puisque le
pion s être attaqué par le fou des 5es
par la tour entre 7
ouais si garry kasparov donc là on va
enlever les traces verte si garry
kasparov lui arrive à jouer le coup je
sais aussi c'est à dire avancer son pion
sur les cases aux 6es biens sont là
l'effet du fou blanc de cases blanches
sera nettement amoindrie et à ce moment
là on peut penser que kasparov arrivant
à faire bull à s'effacer
donc voilà on a ramené ici est en train
de chercher à éviter son cou à cette
sinistre effet tout à fait et dames
c'est de me paraît 9 ces deux parts et
apparel et l'éviter donc ici pronostics
en direct de londres
robert fontaine plus et loire l'ange
choisissent le ku'damm des deux ans ces
deux biens akram nick setta toi tu
attends maintenant c'est à toi de jouer
c'est vrai que ça y est là là il va
jouer là il va jouer c'est sûr vite
remonteront vladimir kramnik la
cigalière très bons plans très beaux
plans il le met ça en regardez donc les
lille vient d'être surpris par garry
kasparov je crois qu'on peut le dire oui
vient d'être surpris krainik est surpris
et surprise il se tâte
il ne sait plus quel de la cale coup
joué alors est-ce qu'on peut envisager
que cramique et ai compris que l'arbitré
ait offert nos remarques et elle n'est
pas envie de jouer pour cette raison oui
ça paraît un peu gros mais bon l'arbitré
toujours l'argent allait il était assis
calmement pendant toute la partie là
kasparov lui a fait une remarque et il
attend fermement krainik là ça va
chauffer peut-être que krainik va jouer
son coup mais rester assis pour là
première venue de la partie pour éviter
toute remarque nous allons assister un
moment un grand moment de ce match la
guerre psychologique qui commence
ladignac ramener contre garry kasparov
le king l'ogre de bakou en difficulté
s'est plaint à l'arbitré donc il fait
intervenir le fameux troisième homme
l'homme qui décide un peu tout l'homme
qui fait la loi dans ce match et oui
alors c'est très chaud c'est très chaud
krainik cependant et c'est un trait sur
sa partie dix minutes seulement alors
que tout à l'heure c'était une heure ça
fait cinquante minutes qui infléchit sur
un camp de minutes de réflexion
c'est exceptionnel c'est en fait cessé
c'est assez russe cc longue réflexion
puisque l'on se rappelle que allant des
shorts ne restez pas dans es si
longtemps scotché à une position à
saillé dalle c'est un incroyable aux
coûts générés par fritz et oui damien a
été joué voilà un superbe enfin superbe
on ne sait pas mais en tout cas le coût
que nous avions recommandé peu son ne
peut pas vraiment sont félicités indemne
c'est un idée nous allons y arriver là
mais c'est un
hop une petite seconde voilà alors il
veut mais l'idée est bien sûr comme tu
le dit d'essayer de prendre le pion en
deux sets mais en c1 l' échiquier de
démonstration si c'est possible à
arisdorf alors alors là l'arbitré venu
que s'est il passé
faudrait c'est lens qui s'est passé on
ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé mais
notre reporter spécial voilà travnik est
parti quand même ça on l'a vu larbitre
aussi
larbitre allaire également d'être parti
et cramique ajoute dames c est donc là
kasparov
alors verra-t-on david esquiva chose
rapidement ou pas déjà premiers paris a
su avant même de regarder la position
moi je pense qu'il va il va jouer assez
rapidement puisqu'il a eu quand même 50
minutes pour réfléchir à toutes les
possibilités que crown il pouvait jouer
et peut-être dans les cinq minutes qui
vont qui viennent jouera sont alors que
s'est il passé
où la bulle arbitres soient enseignées
voulu s'approcher l'état
et voilà kasparov a joué ah oui ils ont
vérifié la pendue voilà apparemment cac
40 se serait plaint que sa pendule
tournerait trop vite
et oui puisqu'il a quand même ça montre
suisse pour peut-être que ça montre
suisse sert à ça en fait ça s'est
vérifié le temps de la pendule pour
éviter tout un acte mais alors la porte
caspar en fabriquer des cartes très
griffiths sacrifice du pion sacrifice du
pion aux est effectivement il a joué qui
avaient des cartes il doit être
convaincu que c'est le alors bon dans la
manette faut absolument qu'on est la
position parce que vraiment c'est très
très choquée et des quatre chroniques
revient à une des rares fois où ils sont
on passe ils sont tous les deux si
effectivement castrophe s'attend à fou
prend des cadets donc ne souhaite pas se
lever puisque cram nique dans cette
position va jouer il faut prendre quatre
c'est une énorme cote
il peut dire que c'est presque 10 mm dix
contre un à peu près pour les fans argué
que la menace est quand même cavalier e
2 donc la bonne assez qu'un milieu de
fourchette
attac double échec au roi d'un côté
attaque là dessus de l'autre côté
donc il faut prendre les 400 prévus faut
prendre un cas c'est clair mais aussi le
coût proposé par stéphane laborde le
ku'damm d un seul à bord il avait
proposé il ya assez longtemps de cela et
effet gratuitement alors là on voit avec
les deux lobo canal web des joueurs en
train de réfléchir vraiment ces succès
ont une noyade une noyade de caracas
mort ça y est ça y est il commence son
spectacle il commence son spectacle
n'est vraiment phénoménal il plisse le
front il lève les yeux ils baissent les
yeux ils soufflent les vraiment terrible
c'est du grand gars arrive c'est du très
grand gars y est chronique
l'air serein a alors informations
nouvelles de stéphane laborde
il faut noter effectivement il faut
noter que kasparov est en pleine
réflexion
merci stéphane pour ses commentaires
avisés important alors chronique ne joue
pas à tempo offrant des cartes alors
peut-être que stéphane a raison et d'âme
des uns est vraiment un coup intéressant
puisqu'il concerne la paire de fou et
protéger les droits à leur relation
poveda peu naturelle à douala ça y est
donc deux possibilités de possibilités
première possibilité proposée par
stéphane laborde donc forcément
intéressante d'âme des uns défend le
pion f3 et contre attaque
le cavalier des quatre ça c'en est une
deuxième possibilité le coup très
logique fou prend fou qui se contente
d'un petit avantage après fou prend fou
tout reprend pion aux 7
et là je crois qu'on peut lire il y a
indiscutablement un avantage blanc sans
aucun risque
c'est clair avec un point en plus c'est
une pression sur f7 lors l'option plus
là on a quatre pions contre 3 ce qui ne
fait donc comme de l'autre côté il ya un
contre un un pion de plus voire même
donc cinq pions contre 4 effectivement
et la pression sanguine 9,7 c'est là que
ça devient important puisque la tour
cette attaque sur l'a7 le fou d un fou
prend des cartes attaque le pion voilà
fou prend des cat's eyes et s'est joué
là kasparov va jouer fou prend des
quatre il vient le jour et comprend un
certain tour points 7 va être jouée par
vladimir kramnik donc là nous sommes en
plein dans la vente que nous analysions
on peut peut-être mettre un plan
d'ensemble sur la salle voilà sur
cramique en train de réfléchir puisque
là nous allons le saisir au vol quand il
veut jouer son coup ce qui ne saurait
tarder il va jouer pour prendre cet
allant l'idée c'est que je pense d'eux
de kasparov c'est de rentrer dans une
finale avec un fou de couleur opposée
puis en moins par exemple surtout
reprend 1,7 essayer un nom je propose
jallet proposé dams et 5 mai sk genres
possibles attentionné regardons bien
crafting va jouer son coup bientôt il va
le faire
kasparov ne bouge plus ne se lève plus
alors ça ça veut dire qu'il attend que
travnik joue c'est sûr quand même il va
jouer
travnik à l'air quand même beaucoup
mieux une grosse tension quand même là
on voit là on voit la question de la
cuisse mais effectivement alors une
information supplémentaire très
importante il faut prendre un badge
effectivement puisque les mesures de
sécurité la salle son maximum il ya des
détecteurs de métaux ce n'est pas un
petit match entre deux petits joueurs
il s'agit d'un gros match entre les deux
plus forts joueurs et donc vous n'avez
pas la possibilité s'ils voulaient venir
un nombre d'en porter un appareil photo
ou une caméra un micro un magnétophone
tout cela est interdit dans la salle
puisque les images sont l'exclusivité de
canal web et de braine games donc
effectivement il ya des mesures de
sécurité très strict et si vous voulez
venir à landreau et versailles studio et
bien
il faut venir mains dans les poches
tranquille pour voir deux gros matches
voilà donc ici c'est surprenant que
comines et encore je t'en prends 200
alors il doit attendre qu'on réfléchisse
à prendre un set
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il a vu alors
finalement en bas je pense qu'on ne
verra peut être à venir jouer son coup
on va revenir à la position
ou alors peut-être est-ce qu est-ce qu
on peut envisager robert que chrome lite
réfléchissent à jouer pour prendre cette
ou encore tours 3e set et je propose nul
a alors à sa vie et celle des images le
tout prend le 7 il ya pas une n'a pas
proposé nul puisque quand même une à un
pion d'avant 10 n'a pas proposé nul et
laka sport va répondre à tempo alors
regardez bien la voilà ça y est ils
jouent il prend sa main hop
il a joué trois sets j'ai l'impression
il a dû jouer un bon coup pour à cet
écrin unique se reprend la tête dans les
mains
hop on pouvait lire maintenant c'est
indiscutable que krainik la cram ni les
plus élevés 4 plus il est en train de
vie c'est garry kasparov
ce qui est quand même rare ce qui est
pas mal du tout net avantage pour
vladimir kramnik kasparov dans les
cordes
maintenant ça va être le monde la
transformation donc là je vous annonce
que si vous suivez le direct et que vous
aimez les échecs vous allez être servi
puisqu'il y en a encore pour au moins
trois bonnes heures de jeu non j'exagère
peut-être un peu mais en tout cas la
partie va être longue et show de robert
g nick je pense raffolent de ces genres
de position il a aucun risque
il va essayer le mât s'est
tranquillement et c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on implante plus aussi
facilement contre casper aurions bon g
nick prendrait son pied dans cette
position c'est à dire par comprennent
que la dernière fois qu à ce partage une
veine folk il allait aussi bien plus ou
moins dans une finale assez difficile et
il a fini par tenir par la main sans
trop de problèmes
enfin ça c'est
c'est quand même que ce prof qui est